So, da bin ich. Ich war heute Morgen schon meine Runde Rennen. Ey, das war echt anstrengend.
Also man merkt das wirklich, der Unterschied, ob man die letzten Tage übelst ungesundes Zeug reingefressen hat oder eben nicht.
Es ist nicht so, als würde ich normalerweise irgendwie absichtlich nur gesundes futtern, aber die letzten Tage war halt sehr fettiges Futter und auch noch sehr viel.
Hat man gemerkt. Allerdings muss ich sagen, meine, die Fitness Tracker App, die sagt immerhin ist es, geil jetzt lädt sie einfach nichts, immerhin ist die Performance Condition am Anfang zwischendurch mal kurz plus 1, am Ende mal wieder minus 1, aber so im Großen und Ganzen halt bei 0.
Also ich hab's nicht ganz so.
Ich hab's nicht ganz so sehr verkackt die letzten Tage.
Small Axis Point, der sich umbenannt hat.
Mit Small Axis Point heißt.
Oh man.
Ich muss heute wahrscheinlich wieder übertrieben viel fressen.
Vielleicht sogar Nudeln mit Lachs heute wieder, man weiß ja nicht.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie lange ich on bin.
Mal gucken, ist ja schon relativ spät.
Spätestens halb 1.
Geh ich was futtern.
Weil nichtdestotrotz, auch wenn ich übelst voll gefressen war die letzten Tage, so langsam, aber sicher merke ich schon, dass ich wieder was essen könnte.
Pepo Fat Time.
Aber ich mein einmal im Jahr so ein paar Tage ordentlich fressen.
Mein, was willst du machen, ja?
Wir wollen ja nicht, dass das High Performer Crimeset Mindset zu sehr Einzug hält hier.
Ich möchte aus dem Gesichtspunkt auch kein Fahrrad, kein Radprofi sein.
Da wird nicht an Weihnachten einfach mal gefressen und irgendwie Zeug gemacht.
Da wird immer ganz genau drauf geguckt, was gefuttert wird.
Und auch an Weihnachten wird jetzt einfach mal 5 Stunden Fahrrad gefahren und sowas.
Also was das angeht, da beneide ich die ja alle nicht.
Wie?
Also Leute, woran merkt man, dass Weihnachten ist?
Dass es für Artstealungs keine Package Updates gibt.
Zwei Tage lang.
Also, also, das ist ja nie der Fall normalerweise.
Achso.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Es gibt keine Updates, man.
Was ist da los?
Normalerweise jedes Mal, wenn ich Package Updates mache, irgendwas ist da immer.
Keine Package Updates.
Arsch, by the way.
Oh, wo ist mein Glas?
Ich hab ne Wasserflasche.
Volle Wasserflasche stehen, aber kein Glas.
Wo hab ich denn das hin?
Ob ich das irgendwie runtergeschmissen hab aus Versehen oder so?
Oh, keine Ahnung.
Wobei ich eh manchmal die übelste...
Opa-Sachen schon mach.
Manchmal frage ich mich dann so nach dem Motto, ey, wo hast du denn deine Uhr hin?
Oder wo hast du denn dein Glas hin?
Und dann steht das irgendwie so auf dem Klo oder so.
So komplett random.
Oder im Wohnzimmer.
Das hatte ich dann irgendwann mal in der Hand.
Bin in den Raum gelaufen, hab's nebenbei hingelegt, was anderes gemacht, da liegen lassen.
Erinnert mich ein bisschen an meine Oma.
Und auch teilweise meinen Opa, die immer ihre Brille gesucht haben.
Und mein Opa hat ja quasi fast geschworen immer, wenn er die Brille nicht gefunden hat, dass er die Brille nicht gefunden hat.
So nach dem Motto, die muss jemand weghaben.
Kann nicht sein, dass der die einfach irgendwo hingelegt hat und vergessen hat.
Die muss jemand weghaben.
Prinzipiell war mein Opa ganz, ganz groß da drin.
So immer, wenn irgendwas nicht da war, wo es sein sollte, das auf andere Leute zu schieben.
Weißt du, woran man bei sich in der Werkstatt so einen Schraubendreher gesucht hat?
Und ich mein, niemand außer ihm ist da in seiner Werkstatt.
Wozu auch, ja?
Den hat er nicht gefunden.
Und da hat er steif und fest behauptet, den muss jemand weghaben.
Und weghaben, das kann gar nicht anders sein.
So nach dem Motto, ja?
Wenn du mich jetzt schon so vor...
Wahrscheinlich hast du dich abends heimlich in die Werkstatt geschlichen und dem versteckt.
Das letzte Mal, fällt mir gerade so ein.
Ich meine, jetzt Weihnachten, kann man sich ein bisschen das olle Zeug...
Ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, wo ich das letzte Mal mit meinem Opa Auto gefahren bin.
Seitdem bin ich nie wieder mit dem Auto gefahren.
Und zwar, der hätte fast, der hätte fast eine Oma auf dem Zebrastreifen überfahren.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, okay, das kann ich mir nicht mehr mit angucken.
Er hat...
Der hatte ja einen Schlaganfall.
Eine ganze Weile, bevor er gestorben ist.
Also, der ist nicht da dran gestorben.
Das war 20 Jahre her oder so.
Das ist gewesen dann.
Und seitdem hat er ein bisschen Probleme gehabt.
So feinmotorisch in den Füßen, ne?
Und irgendwie hat er es geschafft, am Zebrastreifen zu bremsen mit dem Auto.
Und hatte dann irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, wie er das geschafft hat.
Hat er dann irgendwie den Fuß unterm Pedal oder irgendwas gehabt.
Zumindest...
Steht er am Zebrastreifen.
Und so eine Oma läuft über den Zebrastreifen drüber.
Und auf einmal gibt er übelst Gas.
Du hörst den Motor so von 0 auf 100.
Und die Oma macht einen Satz.
Und denkt, sie wird jetzt überfahren.
Und er schafft es gerade noch rechtzeitig, auf die Bremse zu kommen.
Und er hat glücklicherweise die Oma nicht überfahren.
Also nicht meine Oma, sondern eine andere Oma, die da über den Zebrastreifen lief.
Aber die hat sich des Todes erschreckt, die Oma auf dem Zebrastreifen.
Ja.
Und dann hat er auch noch so blöd gelacht im Auto dabei.
Mein Opa hat so blöd gelacht im Auto.
So nach dem Motto, ups, das ist mir aber peinlich.
Die Oma hat ihn aber nur da drinnen sitzen sehen und lachen.
Also die, die, die, die über den Zebrastreifen gelaufen ist.
Und hat gedacht, der alte Sack, der wollte mich erschrecken.
Und das war das letzte Mal, wo ich mit meinem Opa Auto gefahren bin.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, das kann ich mir nicht mehr angucken danach.
Ja, vielleicht auch besser.
Also meine Oma hatte gar keinen Führerschein.
Da ist sie immer mit dem Opa gefahren.
Aber ich glaube, es war damals gar nicht so, gar nicht so unverbreitet, dass nur die Männer Auto gefahren sind.
Ich meine, man darf nicht vergessen.
Mein Opa ist, glaube ich, 1920 oder so geboren gewesen.
Kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Der wäre jetzt 103 ungefähr.
Man muss sich das mal vorstellen.
Es ist nur 100 Jahre her.
Aber die Welt 2020 und 1920 sind einfach komplett.
Ja, sind echt komplett andere Zeiten, so tatsächlich keine Package Updates.
Ich kann es immer noch nicht fassen.
Ja, und Monka ist die Arzt.
Die Arztstilungsleute haben wohl auch Weihnachten, wie es aussieht.
Max ans Trinken erinnern.
Ja, ich habe kein Glas.
Das ist das Problem.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, wo ich das hin habe.
Ich habe es gefunden.
Es stand tatsächlich im Klo.
Was auch immer das da macht.
Schon laufen?
Ja, war ich.
War ich 6,2 Kilometer, also die normale Runde.
Ich wollte heute eigentlich habe ich ja gestern groß angekündigt, die 11 Kilometer Runde laufen.
Aber es war wieder so scheiß Wetter, dass ich mich schon echt überrunden muss, überwinden muss, die 6,2 Kilometer zu laufen und noch mal 5 Kilometer extra.
Hätte ich keinen Bock gehabt.
Moment, mein Hals ist so trocken.
Ich muss jetzt echt was trinken.
Keck Wait.
Und wie war es bei euch gestern Abend?
Für alle, die gestern nicht im Stream umgegammelt haben.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich war bis vor, also bis bis zu Heiligabend eigentlich gar nicht in Weihnachtsstimmung und auch auch so wirklich an Heiligabend nicht ganz, ganz weird.
Ich habe sogar auf dem Handy versucht, mit klassischer Weihnachtsmusik das irgendwie anzuregen.
Aber es hat nicht so richtig funktioniert.
Hat nicht so richtig funktioniert.
Also eigentlich, eigentlich war gestern Abend, also beziehungsweise gestern ein ganz normaler Tag für mich, an dem ich besonders viel gefressen habe.
Das war Weihnachten für mich so in der Kurzfassung.
Besonders Pepo Fett Tag, aber ansonsten eigentlich nix wie groß Besonderes, außer das gefühlt halben Tag die Kirchen Glocken geläutet haben.
Ist ja auch verständlich.
Ich meine, das dürfte der einzige Tag im Jahr sein, vielleicht Oster noch.
Wo das da mal wirklich voll ist.
Früher wurdest du schepp angeguckt, gerade in Bayern, wenn du im Dorf gewohnt hast, nicht in die Kirche gegangen bist.
Heute ist es die Ausnahme, dass die Leute da hingehen.
Ich meine, ich gehe auch nicht hin.
Ihr wisst, ich habe, ich habe es mit so Glaubenssachen ja eh prinzipiell nicht.
Ich glaube, das letzte Mal in der Kirche war ich mit.
Keine Ahnung, war ich das letzte Mal in der Kirche.
Wann macht man Kommunion?
Mit welchem, welchem Alter?
Acht oder so?
Acht.
Ja, da war ich das letzte Mal in der Kirche seitdem nie wieder.
Und der einzige Grund, warum ich das gemacht habe, war ja auch eindeutig, weil ich Geld dafür bekommen habe.
Und nicht zu knapp.
Ich weiß noch, das war das erste Mal, wo ich gemerkt habe, wie nice das ist, wenn man Geld hat.
Ich habe ungefähr 1000 Mark damals eingesammelt zur Kommunion von allen Bekannten und Oma, Opa, Eltern und so.
Da hatte ich insgesamt so, ich glaube, ziemlich, ziemlich glatt 1000 Mark.
Und ich kam mir übertriebenst reich vor.
Aber es ist klar, mit 8, wenn du, wenn du selten, wenn du, wenn du selten mehr als 10 Euro oder 10 Mark mal irgendwie hattest, dann hast du auf einmal 1000.
Meinst du, da ist es immer, ich habe keine Ahnung, aber ich glaube, es gibt zwei, zwei Sachen im Jahr, wo es da voll ist.
Eines, und da dürfte es voller sein, ist wahrscheinlich Weihnachten.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass es Weihnachten, gerade Heiligabend tatsächlich, tatsächlich der einzige Tag im Jahr ist, wo es wirklich voll ist.
In der Kirche und vielleicht noch an Ostern, aber ansonsten eher nicht.
Ich meine, ich gehe, ich gehe so und so nicht hin.
Hey, für mich war das gut.
Ich, ich hatte damals schon mit so religiösen Sachen nix am Hut.
Aber ganz ehrlich, wenn du 8 bist und die Aussicht hast, du gehst ein paar Mal auf so einen Kurs und lässt dich, was, ich weiß gar nicht, was bei der Kommunion eigentlich passiert genau.
Wirst dann irgendwie nochmal extra geweiht vom Pfarrer.
Wobei das im heutigen Kontext, nach dem, was man alles weiß.
Das auch für was anderes stehen könnte.
Zumindest, ich weiß gar nicht, was da, was da passiert.
Ja, also am Ende, am Ende kannst du ja diesen Keks essen.
Oder darfst du diesen, vor der Kommunion darfst du ja diesen Keks nicht futtern.
Warum auch immer.
Ja.
Und wenn du die Auswahl hast zwischen das machen und 1000, 1000 Mark kriegen oder nicht machen.
Dann bist du als 8-Jähriger, sagst du auf jeden Fall, ja, ich mache Kommunion, gibt Money.
Ja, ich, ich sehe da auch überhaupt über, also ganz ehrlich, ich sehe da überhaupt gar nichts Verwerfliches drinne.
Das ist eh alles Schwachsinn.
Warum soll man da nicht ein bisschen die Kohle abgreifen von?
Wenn die Verwandtschaft nur dann die Kohle locker macht, ist doch gut.
Dann machst du, machst du halt Kommunion oder Konfirmation oder Firmung und was es nicht nur alles gibt.
Greifst ein bisschen Kohle ab und gut ist.
Warum nicht?
Ich muss davon nicht überzeugt sein und gezeihen euch.
Guck mal, ist doch wie heute, Leute.
Ne?
Man muss davon nicht überzeugt sein, um Geld dafür zu kassieren.
Guck mal, wie viel blödsinnige Entscheidungen auf der Arbeit so getroffen werden.
Und du denkst dir einfach nur, okay, mehr als sagen kann ich es euch nicht.
Ähm, wenn ihr mich dafür bezahlt, mache ich das.
Und was anderes ist es auch nicht gewesen.
Letztendlich kann das ja jeder machen.
Ich habe nichts dagegen, wenn, wenn, wenn die Leute aus Überzeugung in die Kirche gehen.
Ich denke, das soll jeder machen.
Wie er will.
Für mich ist es nix, egal, ob es jetzt christliche Sachen sind, muslimische Sachen sind, buddhistische Sachen sind oder Scientology, Zeugen Jehovas, was es nicht alles gibt, kann ich alles nix, kann ich mit allem nix anfangen.
Man muss ja sagen, am realistischsten von diesen ganzen Dingern sind, glaube ich, immer noch die Zeugen Jehovas.
Ich glaube nämlich, die Zeugen Jehovas sind das, die erzählen, dass, wenn die Welt unter, es könnte auch Scientology sein, aber ich glaube, es sind die Zeugen Jehovas.
Die erzählen, wenn die Welt untergeht, kommen die Aliens mit dem Raumschiff vorbei und, und, ähm, ja, nehmen die besonders Gläubigen mit.
Also die besonders Gläubigen sind die, die besonders viel bezahlt haben.
Und das ist von allen diesen Dingern noch das, was am wahrscheinlichsten passieren könnte.
Es ist zwar auch sehr unrealistisch, aber das ist zumindest immer noch, ist das Scientology?
Ja, dann sind, dann sind die am realistischen.
Ich meine, das ist, das ist immer noch irgendwie theoretisch.
Möglich, der Rest, oder noch am möglichsten, ja, der Rest eher weniger.
Ja, ähm, es gibt sogar Studien dazu, dass diese Fanboy, Fanboyism-Geschichte, also sei es jetzt, äh, Gaystation vs. Vixbox, oder was, äh, was gab's denn da sonst noch so für Dinger?
Also die, die üblichen Sachen, Nvidia, AMD, Intel, AMD, Apple, Android, was auch immer.
Da gibt es sogar Studien zu.
Dass das in der heutigen Zeit für viele Leute, und ich glaube von Fußballvereinen und sowas müssen wir da gar nicht reden, da ist das auch so.
Aber gerade Marken, und da gibt es tatsächlich Untersuchungen zu, ist für Leute heutzutage Religionsersatz.
Also da gibt es auch tatsächlich so Beobachtungen mit, wie nennt man das so, Gehirn, Gehirnaktivität messen und sowas.
Und da gibt es Leute, besonders große Apple-Fans.
Wenn die Apple-Produkte sehen, wenn die Apple-Produkte gezeigt bekommen, regt das die gleichen Gehirnregionen an, wie wenn ein gläubiger Christ betet.
Kein Witz, könnt ihr nachgucken.
Also da gibt es tatsächlich große Parallelen dazwischen.
Und wenn man das weiß, muss man sich gar nicht so sehr wundern, warum das oftmals diese, diese ganzen Fanboy-Kriege zwischen den unterschiedlichen Herstellern, Produkten und Marken,
warum die oftmals...
weil es mit sehr viel Überzeugung, aber wenig Fakten geführt werden, ist im Prinzip einfach religiöses Gelaber.
Oder sehr ähnlich zu religiösem Gelaber.
Ja, wer kennt nicht Tim Apple?
Es ist so schlimm, ich weiß gar nicht, wie der Typ richtig heißt.
Äh, Cook, Cook heißt er, genau.
Ich sag auch immer nur Tim Apple, man.
Cook.
Yep, yep, Cook.
Du hast gestern das YouTube-Video enjoyed.
Das ist...
Exzellent.
Nice YouTube-Enjoyer.
Ah ja.
Wir können jetzt nicht schon wieder Github-Trends gucken, weil Github-Trends haben wir uns schon angeschaut und da wird sich wahrscheinlich...
Ne, nicht wirklich.
Da wird sich, wird sich wahrscheinlich seit Sonntag nicht viel verändert haben.
Muss grad mal die Stats einblenden, weil es hat grad geruckelt.
Hat es bei euch auch geruckelt?
Nö.
Dann lag das an meinem Rechner, dass es geruckelt hat.
Also geruckelt ist falsches Wort.
Es hat kurz gebuffert.
Auf meinem Vorschau, Vorschau-Rechner-Screen.
Und, äh, wenn es buffert, dann deutet das, dann deutet das meistens darauf hin, dass Vodafone wieder irgendwie verkackt.
Aber es buffert gar nicht.
Das lag an meinem Vorschau-Rechner.
Ah, gut.
Und jetzt, Chat?
Was machen wir jetzt?
Ach, ich weiß, was wir machen.
Ich hab noch zwei Discord, Discord-Gifts.
Discord-Gifts.
Discord-Nitro-Premium.
Mit Server-Boosts.
Zwei, zwei Server-Boosts.
Dabei.
Ja, komm, machen wir einen jetzt.
Machen wir einen jetzt und einen später.
Also, ich werd jetzt gleich hier ins Notepad einen Discord-Gift-Link posten.
Und wer ihn als erstes einlöst, gewinnt.
Beziehungsweise kann ihn, kann ihn einlösen.
Ja.
Also, ihr habt zwei Möglichkeiten, das Ganze zu machen.
Entweder ihr seid schnell und tippt das ab.
Ihr könnt auch irgendeine OCR-Software verwenden oder was auch immer.
Ist mir wurscht.
Wer am schnellsten ist, kriegt ihn.
Also, drei, zwei, eins, bam.
So, da muss ich das gleich mal markieren als benutzt.
Gibt's was Neues wegen der Versicherung deinem Fahrradunfall?
Ups, ja und nein.
Also, ich hab das ja bei einem Anwalt liegen.
Der hat da hingeschrieben und die Versicherung hat jetzt gesagt,
und das ist auch schon ein paar Wochen her, hat gesagt,
sie haben keine Einsprüche gegen unsere Ansprüche.
Ich glaub, so haben sie das geschrieben.
Aber Geld haben sie immer noch nicht.
Geld haben sie immer noch nicht überwiesen.
Der Anwalt hat sogar schon zweites Mal hingeschrieben,
dass die nochmal aufgefordert werden.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum das so ein großer Akt ist.
Ich mein, das ist komplett...
Die ist komplett unstrittig, ne?
Die ist komplett über die Vorfahrt gefahren, hat mich umgefahren.
Keiner widerspricht der ganzen Geschichte.
Okay, wurde eingelöst.
Discord-Enjoyer.
Die könnten theoretisch noch am gleichen Tag überweisen, so.
Aber, ja, machen sie nicht.
Ich mein, es ist jetzt auch nicht schlimm.
Ich brauch nicht die Kohle, um ihr neues Fahrrad kaufen zu können.
Das größere Problem, was ich aktuell habe, ist,
dass es das Fahrrad, was ich haben will,
gerade nicht in meiner Größe lieferbar ist
und auch gerade nicht mit der Schaltung lieferbar ist.
In meiner Größe, die ich haben will.
Also, Schaltung liegt daran,
weil es die in elektronischer Form noch gar nicht gibt,
sondern erst nächstes Jahr.
Und, ja, das Fahrrad nicht in meiner Größe.
Die Farbe ist mir fast egal.
Ich will wieder das gleiche Fahrrad wie das letzte Mal.
Das hier.
Das da.
Allerdings hätte ich gerne einmal zwölf anstelle einmal elf.
Und das ist ja nicht so.
Und einmal zwölf gibt es noch nicht.
Hast du schon den Discord-Nitro-Exploit gesehen mit Opera GX?
Nein?
Zeig mal.
Discord-Nitro-Exploit.
Opera GX.
Opera GX?
Accidental Free Discord-Nitro-Generator?
What?
Lustig.
Hey, da hätte ich euch ja gar keine Discord-Nitro schenken müssen,
wenn wir es einfach kostenlos generieren.
Wenn wir es einfach kostenlos generieren können.
Hol dir doch das hier.
Was es nicht alles gibt, Mann.
Das ist mir erstens ein bisschen teurer, zu teuer.
Und zweitens ist das von der Sitzposition mir zu unangenehm.
Oder mir zu unergonomisch.
Das ist ja witzig.
Also eins muss man lassen.
Die.
Kann man das noch Lackierung nennen?
Die Bemalung ist echt nice.
Es ist alles.
Guck mal, es ist komplett.
Es ist komplett ausverkauft.
Komplett ausverkauft.
Die Weeps sind überall.
Weep-Bikes.
Also, man, sie hätten ja noch was an den Reifen machen können, ne?
Man hätte ja durchaus die Reifen noch verweibisieren können.
Man hat genug Platz.
Das sind garantiert Carbon-Reifen bei dem Preis.
Und die hätte man ja sicherlich auch noch bemalen können.
Zumal das ja auch Scheibenbremsen hat.
Das heißt, hier brauchst du ja gar nix drauf.
Man hätte hier garantiert die auch noch verweibisieren können.
Drei Reviews.
Hellen.
Ja, meine ich.
Oh.
Guck mal hier.
Hier gibt es sogar Fotos von.
Also, ich muss schon sagen, ich finde die Bemalung schon nice irgendwie.
Jetzt nicht so hundertprozentig meinen Geschmack, dass ich sie kaufen würde.
Wie gesagt, auch das Rad würde ich mir nicht kaufen.
Aber.
Die Idee finde ich cool.
Hat was.
Weep-Bike.
Laufräder.
Ja, wie war das jetzt mit.
Moment.
Wie war das jetzt mit Discord.
Discord Nitro Opera GX.
Opera GX Accidental Free Discord.
Okay.
Free Discord Nitro.
What?
Okay, das müssen wir uns mal kurz angucken.
Das interessiert mich.
Ich meine, ich habe eh ein Discord-Abo.
Ich habe eh immer.
Wobei.
Was?
Hat Discord noch was anderes als Nitro?
Ich habe eh, ich habe, ich habe so ein, so ein Discord-Discord-Abo.
Was, weiß ich nicht, was das kostet.
Fünf Euro oder so.
Opera GX ist eine Monat lang free Discord Nitro.
Das Ding ist halt, ich würde nicht mal dafür freiwillig Opera GX benutzen.
But there is an issue with it.
It's actually a free Nitro generator.
But how much Nitro can you generate?
A hundred codes?
A thousand codes?
A hundred thousand codes?
Well, before descending into the exploit rabbit hole, let's take a step back.
Das ist doch bestimmt schon gefixt, oder?
Das ist doch bestimmt schon gefixt.
Promotion works.
So, if you haven't been on the internet for the past couple of days, Opera GX is giving
you one month of free Discord Nitro.
It's a promotion, and it ends on June 17th, 2024, so you have tons of time to redeem and
exploit the heck out of this thing.
But the way to claim this Discord Nitro is, you need to go to the link in the description,
and you will see this page here.
Now, uh, the tutorial's pretty easy.
You click on how to claim, and it's gonna tell you to download Opera GX.
Warum, warum, warum sieht, warum sieht diese Seite, diese Seite schon so, so aus?
Okay, das würde ich, wenn überhaupt, schon mal nur in der VM machen, weil bei mir käme keine China-Chinesen-Software drauf.
Was? Was?
Ja, Moment, die muss man in Opera GX aufmachen.
Okay, schon mal, schon mal gelitten, weil hab ich.
Hab ich.
Eigentlich sind das ziemlich coole Sachen, um Discord-Server zu boosten, ja.
Okay, ich, ich vermute mal, die haben das folgendermaßen gemacht.
Jedes Mal, wenn du Opera GX installierst, wird eine Random-ID generiert,
die halt einmal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal,
die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal
die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die
andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere
Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal, die andere Mal
Und boostet seinen Discord. Ja gut, kann man machen.
Ja, mal in den Payload reingucken.
Okay, was, was, was, was muss da alles drin stehen?
Also, es ist ein Post-Request, es muss, okay, ein paar Header müssen gesetzt sein.
Das ist wahrscheinlich relativ egal.
Das da ist wahrscheinlich wichtig.
Content-Type könnte eventuell auch wichtig sein.
Origin-Referrer könnte in dem Fall tatsächlich auch wichtig sein.
Das hier muss da bestimmt auch rein.
Da muss auf jeden Fall was Valid-mäßiges drinstehen, gehe ich mal von aus.
Ja, ist wahrscheinlich das.
Okay, hier, Data-Raw, Partner-User-ID.
Das ist wahrscheinlich das, was random generated wird, wenn man auf diese Seite geht.
Oder den, ja, theoretisch, theoretisch dachte ich,
wenn man den Browser neu installiert, aber anscheinend reicht das ja, wenn man die Seite refresht.
Und das sieht, das sieht übrigens wie eine ganz normale UUID aus.
Also eine ganz normale GUID sieht das aus.
Die kannst du ja in jeder x-beliebigen Programmiersprache easy generaten.
That, uh, we get this weird little token.
And I'm just gonna copy this random little token,
and I am going to paste it into my notepad.
Now I'm seeing something that matches up here.
This EYJH thing also matches up with this EYJH thing.
So what if I just, uh, delete this from the link,
and, uh, I put in my new, uh, my new little special token,
and I paste it in, and I copy this URL,
and I, uh, put it in my browser.
Und sieh da, es funktioniert.
Ja.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich nice.
Das kann man wunderbar ohne Opera GX,
das kann man automatisieren.
Now, I could keep on clicking send over and over again
and copying every single one of these gift links,
but I'm lazy.
So I click on this little drop-down,
and I click on, uh, repeat on...
Ja, das würde ich, das würde ich nicht machen.
Ich würde das tatsächlich in Asian Script, äh, stecken und gut ist.
Aber trotzdem muss ich sagen, es hält sich wahrscheinlich in Grenzen.
Ich meine, du musst jedes Mal, um das akzeptieren zu können,
äh, in den Browser gehen, Zahlungsmethoden eintragen.
Sogar das könntest du nicht machen.
Das könntest du theoretisch automatisieren
über irgendwie Puppeteer oder sowas mit einem Headless Chrome.
Wie, wie auch immer, kannst du das bestimmt fernsteuern lassen.
Aber du brauchst jedes Mal einen neuen Account,
du brauchst jedes Mal Zahlungsmethoden.
Das Einzige, wozu sich das wirklich lohnen würde, ist,
wenn man halt wie verrückt einen Discord-Server boosten möchte
und free boosts braucht.
Dafür, dafür macht das Sinn.
Und mit diesem kann ich tausende Nitro-Promotions-Codes machen.
Ich kann diese Karten anrufen,
aber du brauchst für jeden Code einen eigenen Discord-Account.
Was bringen die Boosts?
Ja, also eigentlich bringen die Boosts jetzt nicht wirklich viel.
Du kannst zum Beispiel größere Dateianhänge benutzen, glaube ich, dann im Discord.
Du kannst die Sprachqualität von den Voice-Channels hochstellen
ab einer gewissen Anzahl von Boosts.
Die Emote-Anzahl erhöht sich,
aber so grundlegend ist jetzt,
ist das nicht irgendwie anders, nur weil das geboostet ist.
Du hast so ein paar kleinere Vorteile bei dem Server.
Ist auch ganz sinnvoll mit den Boosts gemacht,
weil das halt auch nur Server, die ein bisschen frequentiert werden, geboostet werden,
was auch Discord Geld spart
und durch die Verkaufsboost auch was bringt,
sodass im Prinzip nur die Server, wo eine gewisse Anzahl an Leuten drauf sind,
dann auch geboostet ist für bessere Quali.
Aber insofern, jetzt kann jeder seinen Ein-Mann-Server auf, äh,
fünf Punkte oder was das Höchste ist, boosten.
Oh, in my Discord-Server.
I would become a cult leader by giving what these beggars want.
Free Discord Nitro.
I would be the most powerful Discord degenerate on the platform
with my thousands of Nitro-Promotion links
and everyone selling all 144,000 for $10 on PayPal.
And this guy attached an image of, uh, 144,000 Discord-Nitro-
Okay, der hat's, der wollte es halt bis,
für 10 Dollar.
Also, ganz ehrlich, das würde ich nicht kaufen.
Also, ich meine, eventuell würde ich es eh selbst generieren.
Aber das würde ich nicht kaufen, weil es einfach nach Scam klingt.
Für 10 Dollar.
Es ist wahrscheinlich gar kein Scam in dem Fall, aber
es klingt nach Scam.
Manche Sachen musst du teurer machen, dass es glaubwürdiger klingt.
Damit er 10 Dollar auf PayPal bekommen kann.
Damit er 10 Dollar auf PayPal kommen kann.
Ist das, ist das das neue High-Performer-Crimeset Mindset
wie man, wie man das krasse Business macht jetzt?
Discord-Promotion-Links generieren
As noise into even more money.
Not that much.
Und dann kannst du Server-Boosts verkaufen, oder wie?
Ja, genau, du kannst Server-Boosts verkaufen für 50 Cent oder so.
Ja, klar.
Na gut, du machst ja eigentlich nichts Illegales, aber Discord kann sich halt bannen überall.
Ne, ich glaube nicht, dass du irgendwas Verbotenes machst in dem Fall.
Also du machst vielleicht was gegen Discord Terms of Service, aber da kann ja nichts rechtlich für groß passieren.
Du kannst sogar Nitro-Boosts verkaufen an diesem Punkt, weil ich dieses Video gemacht habe und den ganzen Markt zerstört habe.
Ja, genau.
Und immer neue Accounts, ist das eigentlich jetzt, sagen wir mal, zu aufwendig, um irgendwie groß lukrativ zu sein.
Denke ich.
Man weiß ja nie, wie weiter die Leute gehen.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es so einfach ist.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es so einfach ist.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es so ein großes Ding ist.
Aber es ist schon komisch, dass sie das nicht gemerkt haben.
Ich meine, das ist doch obviously, dass es da Probleme gibt, oder?
Übrigens, das wollte ich mir gleich mal angucken.
Irgendwelche verrückten Leute speedrun Mario 64 jetzt mit Augenbinde und stellen da Weltrekorde auf.
Jetzt irgendwie nachher.
Ich habe von ihm schon mal ein Video gemacht.
Ich habe schon mal ein Video geguckt, genau.
120 Sterne.
120 Sterne mit Augenbinde auf.
Aber das habe ich mir nicht ganz angeguckt, weil das Video geht halt einfach 11 Stunden.
Ich meine, 11 Stunden, Alter.
Das ist schon etwas, wie sagt man so, Dedication, das durchzuhalten.
Was verdient ein Wagenbauer?
So was gibt es noch?
Ich würde mir einfach China-Chinesen Wagen holen.
Windows.
Windows 10 Abo.
Ab jetzt zahlen für Windows 10.
Warum sollte ich das machen?
Windows 10 nach seinem Support-Ende zum Abo wird.
Ach so.
Ja, logisch.
Irgendwie war es...
Habe ich sowas nicht sogar in einem der letzten Streams gesagt?
Wie wäre es mit einem Abo-Modell für Windows 10?
Weil wir hatten es doch davon, Verbreitung von Windows 10, Support-Ende und sowas.
Und dass sie ganz bestimmt nicht...
Ja, verlängert es sich.
Ganz bestimmt nicht.
Wenn sie sich jetzt das aufs Spiel stellen wollen.
Ich meine, Microsoft hat sich wirklich sehr angestrengt,
dass es Security-technisch sowohl von den Problemen, die es unter Windows gibt,
als auch der Ruf sich deutlich gebessert hat die letzten Jahre.
Die werden jetzt nicht ein System, was noch über 50% Verbreitung hat,
einfach mal sterben.
Ja.
Also.
Und ich glaube, eines der Sachen, die ich gesagt habe,
ist, warum machen sie nicht einfach ein Abo am Ende draus?
Also, ich persönlich habe ja darauf spekuliert,
dass die jetzt viel unternehmen werden, um dich dazu zu bringen, auf Windows 11 abzucraden.
Und wenn das...
Also, und auch ein paar Gängelungen einbauen,
so wie man das mit Windows 7 damals gemacht hat.
Und wenn es immer noch nicht bis zum Support-Ende ausreicht,
dann wird das Ganze verlängert.
Und ich persönlich gehe auch davon aus, immer noch, dass es verlängert wird.
Es sei denn, alle schwenken jetzt auf dieses Abo um
und Microsoft verdient sich da eine goldene Nase dran.
Aber what the fuck?
Ja, jetzt Updates nach dem Support-Ende am 14. Oktober.
Das heißt, wer das Jahr 2025 erhalten will, der muss zahlen.
Microsoft hat es also nach so vielen erfolglosen Versuchen,
Windows in ein Abo-Modell zu verwandeln, endlich geschafft.
Wir werden bald monatlich oder jährlich für den...
Eigentlich ist das doch mal von Microsoft absolute Six-Head-Taktik.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es wirklich Taktik von Anfang an war.
Aber man weiß nicht.
Überlegt euch mal.
Überlegt euch doch mal.
Ihr seid Microsoft.
Ihr bringt Windows 10 raus.
Windows 10 kommt ganz gut an.
Windows 10...
Windows 10 ist beliebt.
Windows 10 ist verbreitet.
Dann bringt ihr absichtlich einen selbst gehypten Nachfolger raus,
den nur ihr selbst abfeiert,
der aber absichtlich Abfuck ist für die Leute,
sodass sie lieber auf Windows 10 bleiben wollen.
Dann sagt ihr ihnen, ihr könnt Windows 11 weiter benutzen,
aber Windows 10 hat Support-Ende 2025.
Aber wenn ihr es weiter benutzen wollt, dann kauft doch ein Abo dafür.
Also die könnten quasi da...
Überlegt euch mal, wie schlau das eigentlich wäre.
Du bringst absichtlich einen scheiß Nachfolger raus,
damit die Leute ein Abo für das Vorgängermodell kaufen.
Das wäre...
Ich glaube, das ist eine Nummer zu Six-Head für Microsoft.
Aber das wäre die...
Das ist ja richtig...
Schlongsplan.
...Bezahlung von Windows.
Bezahlen müssen.
Erst mal, was haltet ihr von der News?
Ich bin echt gespannt auf...
Ich glaube nicht, dass sich das groß durchsetzen wird.
Also das Erste, was passieren wird, ist,
es gibt alternative Möglichkeiten, die Updates zu installieren aus dem Abo-Modell.
Dann hast du dann irgendeinen, der hat ein Abo bei Microsoft
und erstellt die dann über einen privaten Update-Server bereit oder sowas.
Wird es garantiert geben.
Gut, ich habe das Problem nicht mehr.
Ich bin jetzt unter Windows 11.
Auf dem Rechner.
Auf dem anderen habe ich noch Windows 10.
Aber mal gucken, wie das bis 2025 aussieht.
Meinungen zu dem Thema.
Heute reden wir darüber, was das für Windows 10-Nutzer bedeutet.
Wie genau dieses Abo-Modell aussehen wird und auch, was ihr als Windows 10-User jetzt tun solltet.
Aber zuvor noch diese...
Kein Abo kaufen.
...Nachricht von unserem heutigen Videosponsor, der absolut nicht will, dass ihr ihm monatlich Geld überweist.
Stellt euch vor, ihr müsstet nie wieder monatlich für euren Online-Speicher bezahlen.
Mit pCloud ist das möglich.
Sichert euch eine lebenslange Cloud-Lizenz...
Sass.
Wenn irgendwie einer zu mir sagt, Lifetime-Dinger, da bin ich immer sehr skeptisch.
Ich erinnere mal daran, ich habe mir auch mal eine VM gekauft.
Bei...
Wie hießen die?
Ja, ich weiß es wieder.
Cloud...
Cloud at Costs hießen die.
Weiß gar nicht, ob es die noch gibt.
Oh.
Hahaha.
Okay.
Ja.
Die Bewertung haben sie anscheinend verdient, hä?
Legit ein Stern.
Guck mal, die haben auch...
Pay once, keep server forever.
Die haben den gleichen Kram gekauft wie ich.
One-Time-Pay-Option.
Das ist genau der gleiche Kram, den ich auch gekauft habe, worüber die sich aufregen.
Zumindest, die haben das damals verkauft.
Einmal bezahlen und für immer kostenlos.
Und das hielt irgendwie drei, vier Jahre.
Und dann wurde die VM abgeschafft.
Und dann haben sie gesagt, ja, die ist ja weiterhin Lifetime kostenlos, aber ihr müsst eine Maintenance-Fee bezahlen.
Von, glaub, 14 Euro oder so.
Und da habe ich mir damals überlegt, Moment.
Heißt Lifetime kostenlos nicht eigentlich auch, ich muss keine 14 Euro Maintenance-Fee bezahlen, dass die weiterläuft?
Sie haben natürlich nicht gesagt, sie bezahlen was, also man müsste was für die VM bezahlen.
Die ist natürlich weiterhin kostenlos.
Aber eine Maintenance-Fee musste man bezahlen.
Und ich habe die Maintenance-Fee nie bezahlt und seitdem ist die VM aus.
Das ist schon Jahre her.
Und hast du dir die AGB?
Nö, habe ich nicht.
Es war jetzt auch nicht teuer.
Ich glaube, das hat 29 Euro gekostet oder so damals für eine Lifetime-VM.
Und ich dachte mir, ohne Mist, kauf dir das einfach mal.
Du kriegst für immer eine Public-IPv4-Adresse.
Allein schon das ist einmalig 29 Euro wert.
Also das ist wirklich sehr shady gewesen alles.
Deswegen, sobald jetzt einer hier um die Ecke kommt und sagt, dass ich Lifetime irgendwas bekomme,
den glaube ich das nur sehr ungerne.
Und vor allem Lifetime, wenn es dir von irgendeiner Company gesellt wird, heißt ja immer Lifetime, solange es den Laden gibt.
Wenn es den Laden mal irgendwann nicht mehr gibt, ist mit Lifetime vorbei.
Zum Beispiel, letztens habe ich ein Video gesehen von, wie heißt der, Louis Rossmann, der auch immer was von
von
von Recht aufs Reparieren und so erzählt.
Der hat erzählt von einer Audiobearbeitungssoftware, die auch quasi mit Lifetime-Lizenz
Hups, ja, ja, ist ja gut, ist ja gut.
Mit Lifetime-Lizenz verkauft wurde.
Da wurde jetzt nachträglich ein Cloud-Abo reingepatcht und die alte Funktion, die alte Version nicht mehr aktivierbar gemacht,
damit die Leute upgraden, obwohl es ein Lifetime-Abo war oder Lifetime, Lifetime.
Code war, ja.
In dem heutigen Video, ihr müsstet, sichert euch eine Lebenslage.
Okay, dann gucken wir mal, ob das auch Scam ist.
Cloud-Lizenz mit 2 oder 10 Terabyte Speicherplatz, momentan sogar zum weihnachtlichen Angebotspreis mit 85% Reise.
Aha.
So zahlt ihr für 2 Terabyte Speicher nur einmalig 499 Euro und für 10 Terabyte einmalig.
Ja, das ist aber auch schon mal ein ganz schöner Batzen, ja.
Ich meine, 10 Terabyte Festplatte kostet dich 200 Euro oder so.
Ey gut, das ist halt auch nicht in der Cloud und nicht Offsite.
Das hat schon sein Fortarbeit schon.
Wisst ihr, was die Sache ist?
Wie kann man darauf zugreifen, ist die große Frage.
Das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken.
The most secure, ja, ja, ja.
Okay, wo kommen die her?
Die kommen, sieht man das irgendwo?
Die kommen aus Server Location.
In der EU, ja, ja, wo kommen die denn her?
Contact us.
Aus der Schweiz.
Aus Bar.
Okay, schon mal kein China-Chinesen-Zeug.
So, Pricing.
Lifetime 10 Terabyte oder Lifetime 2 Terabyte.
So, und die Frage ist, fair sharing.
Die Frage ist, wie kann man darauf zugreifen?
Das wäre jetzt natürlich die eigentliche Frage.
Braucht man einen eigenen Client von denen?
Geht das nur über das Webinterface?
Gibt es vielleicht sogar eine Möglichkeit, das Linux-Filesystem technisch zu mounten?
Man weiß es nicht so genau.
Hättest du eine Storagebox, kann SSH, ich weiß.
Die ist aber auf Dauer dann sicherlich teurer.
Oh, Windows.
Moment, man muss diese komische pCloud-App verwenden.
Gut, da hätte ich schon mal keinen Bock drauf.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Moment, das ist Windows-only?
Ja, das ist schon mal blöd.
Ich meine, zumindest ein Mac-Client hätte ich jetzt mal.
Ah, ne, Moment, da oben.
Ich bin ja PP-ge, Alter.
Linux.
pCloud für Linux.
Also available as a CLI-Version.
Okay, ich meine, das ist schon ein bisschen älter, aber.
Gucke mal.
Es gibt sogar die Möglichkeit, das als Linux-Laufwerk, als Fuse.
Oder als Fuse.
Ähm.
Laufwerk-Device zu mounten.
Gar nicht mal so übel.
Vermutlich.
Zumindest.
Gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Muss ich sagen.
Hey, why not?
Frage ist, wie maintained das ist, wenn das letzte Update vor zwei Jahren gewesen ist.
Mount point.
Mindpoint.
Okay, das ist in der Tat besser, als ich gedacht hätte.
Also, dass es einen Fuse-Client gibt oder ein Fuse.
Ich sag immer Fuse.
Ich meine.
Eigentlich heißt es Fuse, aber irgendwie
weiß ich nicht, Fuse
Das ist
Ey, guck mal
Es wird sogar offiziell
Arch, by the way
Nicht schlecht
Okay, seriously
Die haben mich insofern ein bisschen überzeugt von sich
Natürlich würde ich mich nicht auf die
eingebaute Encryption verlassen, sondern würde
selbst encrypten auf Pfeilebene
Aber
ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht so kacke
Gar nicht so kacke, wie ich gedacht habe
Jetzt überspringen wir das mal
was mit Windows 10 und Abo-Modell los ist
Ich habe bereits in einem vorherigen
Video hier auf WindowsArea.de
darüber gesprochen, warum Windows
10 zum Problem werden könnte
für Microsoft
Das hatten wir schon
Was ist jetzt mit der Abo-Geschichte los?
Das Windows-Abo ist da
Aber jetzt hat es Microsoft tatsächlich umgesetzt
und das Abo-Windows kommt
Nach dem Supportende am 14. Oktober 2025
wird es wieder für Windows 10
Extended Security Updates geben
Das war bei vorherigen Versionen von Windows ebenfalls so
Windows 7 hat die bekommen
und auch Windows XP hat die extrem lange bekommen
Nur eben diesmal mit dem Unterschied
dass das Abonnement nicht nur für Unternehmen
sondern auch für Privatkunden angekündigt wurde
Früher konnten sich nur Unternehmen
für diese Extended Security Updates
oder ESU-Updates registrieren
und eben jährlich dafür bezahlen
Und da bleibt natürlich die spannende Frage offen
Was wird das kosten?
Da müssen wir tatsächlich einen Blick in die Vergangenheit werfen
Denn Microsoft hat offizielle Preise noch nicht
Naja, seriously, die normalen Preise
für Extended Support Updates
waren so irrwitzig hoch
dass es garantiert kein normaler
Privat-User machen würde
Aber ESU-Updates für Windows 7
kosteten zwischen 25
und 200 Euro pro Jahr
und pro Gerät
Abhängig natürlich von der Edition
25 geht
25 geht ja noch
Aber 200 wäre es mir dann schon fraglich
ob es mir das wert wäre
Oftmals von der Größe
Und wir reden ja pro Device
Pro Device
Und jetzt überlegt euch mal
Ihr seid eine Firma gewesen
die noch 100
Windows 7 Kisten hatte
Könnt ihr einfach nochmal zwei Nullen dranhängen
Das sind einfach nur 20.000 Euro
...des Unternehmens
Viele Bildungseinrichtungen haben da oftmals
ziemlich großzügige Rabatte von Microsoft bekommen
auf diese ESU-Updates
wenn sie einfach ihre Hardware
noch nicht upgraden konnten
Im ersten Jahr waren diese ESU-Updates
immer etwas günstiger
und sie wurden eben zum Ende
des Unterstützungszeitraums
immer teurer eben
weil Microsoft auch dann die Nutzer dazu kriegen will
eine neuere Windows-Version eben zu installieren
oder eben einen neuen PC zu kaufen
Für Windows 7 gab es ESU-Updates
nur drei Jahre lang
und im dritten Jahr wurden
zwischen 100 und 200 Euro fällig
Ich könnte mir vorstellen
dass Microsoft die Preise für Privatkunden
doch etwas attraktiver gestalten wird
Ja, weil sonst wird es keiner machen
Ich würde ganz ehrlich eine Summe zwischen 12 und 25 Euro
im ersten Jahr vermuten
und einigermaßen nachvollziehen können
Auch wenn ich eigentlich ein Windows-Abo ablehne
wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin
Und wenn ich schon selber nicht wirklich bereit bin
Aber ich kann euch ehrlich gesagt sagen
was passieren wird
Irgendjemand stellt einen privaten Windows-Server
Windows-Update-Server zur Verfügung
über den man das runter
Oder aber wenn du das nicht so machen willst
kriegst du wahrscheinlich irgendeinen
Kannst du dir selbst einen Windows-Update-Server installieren
und kannst dir die Updates irgendwo runterladen
und sowas
Also das wird schon funktionieren
Oder du brauchst nur ein Abo
für alle deine Geräte daheim und sowas
Kann man bestimmt tricksen
Ich bin dafür, für ein Windows-Abo zu bezahlen
Dann kann ich mir vorstellen
dass die Akzeptanz bei generellen Nutzern
nicht sehr groß sein wird
Entsprechend kann ich mir nicht ganz vorstellen
dass das Abo so teuer sein wird
wie eben für Unternehmen
Es könnte aber auch
Aber wer weiß
Vielleicht ist genau das Ziel von Microsoft
Es könnte auch ein bisschen Säbelrasseln von Microsoft sein
So nach dem Motto
Ihr könnt Windows 10 weiter benutzen
Aber dann wird es teuer
Also upgrade doch mal zackig auf Windows 11
Weil die Windows 11-Verbreitung
Wir können ja gleich nochmal in die Statistiken gucken
Letztes Mal als ich geguckt habe
waren die noch nicht so geil
Das ist die einzige Alternative
die Nutzer zum Windows 10-Abo für Extended Updates haben
Einen neuen PC zu kaufen
mit Windows 11
oder bis dahin nicht mehr zu kaufen
und bis dahin potenziell auch Windows 12
Und das ist nicht gerade günstiger
Aber wie gesagt
Microsoft hat bisher keine Preise dazu genannt
Und daher ist das alles im Grunde nur Spekulation
bis Microsoft eben nicht offiziell rauskommt
mit diesen Preisen
und was das alles kosten wird
Und das könnte uns noch sehr überraschen
wie teuer das tatsächlich wird
Aber es wird halt vor allem davon abhängen
Was genau hat Saruman damit zu tun?
Was Microsofts Ziel ist
mit diesem Abo-Modell für Windows 10
Ist es deren Ziel, Geld zu verdienen?
Für die Entwicklung?
Das heißt wir wissen es nicht
Also ehrlich gesagt haben wir alle keine Ahnung
Aber gucken wir mal
Windows 11-Verbreitung
Ich glaube es war immer noch so
dass 70% der Leute glaube ich
Windows 10 benutzen
Per-brei-tung
Ok hier
Windows 11 sichert sich rund ein Viertel
der Windows-Marktanteile
Schaut mal auf die aktuelle Verteilung!
Verteilung laufen immer noch rund 69%
69% aller Windows-Rechner weltweit
Da war ich mit 70% doch gar nicht so schlecht
So habe ich das nämlich auch im Hinterkopf
70% haben Windows 10
Und sollte das bis Ende 2025
oder Oktober ist es glaube ich
Oktober 2025
immer noch über 50%
oder 50 reicht ja gar nicht
Über 30% sein
30-40%
Dann wird Microsoft noch irgendwas machen
Bin ich mir relativ sicher
Die lassen nicht 30-40%
ihren Ruf den sie sich aufgebaut haben
als nicht mehr ganz so offen wie ein Scheunentor zu sein
dadurch zerstören
Glaube ich nicht
Windows 11 bleibt weiter unbeliebt
Ja wundert mich nicht
Es kann auch durchaus sein
dass es bis dahin Windows 12 gibt
Mal gespannt wie sie uns Windows 12 dann schmackhaft machen wollen
Ich meine bei Windows 11 haben sie ja schon fast geweint
in der Präsentation
wie emotional sie sind
Mal gucken was sie bei Windows 12 dann machen
Es wird gebastelt
Keno versucht seinen Rechner zusammenzubauen
Ja
Oh oh Leute!
Leute habt ihr es gesehen?
Habt ihr es gesehen?
Millimeter
Wer sieht es noch?
Ganz klar zu sehen
Mikrorisse im Mainboard Leute
Hahaha
Eindeutig Mikrorisse
Wie bei mir
Mein Rechner ist ja auch angeblich voller Mikrorisse
Zumindest sagt es
Zumindest sagt das der Twitch Chat
Weiß ich auch nicht
Der Twitch Chat hat gesagt
Ich bekomme Mikrorisse bei mir im Mainboard
Als ich meinen PC zusammengebaut habe
Da hat der Chat
Der Chat hat die ganze Zeit erzählt
Max du bekommst Mikrorisse im Mainboard
Wusste damals auch nicht warum
Und ich glaube auch nicht dass ich Mikrorisse habe
Weil mein Rechner funktioniert wunderbar
Hahaha
Weil du das Anti-Static-Armband nicht anhattest
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr über was ich angeblich Mikrorisse bekommen habe
Ich glaube
Ich glaube weil ich den Ständer der Grafikkarte nicht richtig drunter hatte oder sowas
Oder warum
Weil ich den Abstandhalter
Weil ich den Abstandhalter am Mainboard nicht richtig dran hatte
Irgendwas wegen irgendwas bekomme ich Mikrorisse angeblich
Doch jetzt kommen wir zu den guten Sachen
Monkess
Jeden Tag League of Legends verdienen was mit E-Sport
Guck mal hier das ist mein neuer
Alter
Das ist sein neuer PC
Okay lasst mal kurz schauen was er da drinnen hat
Inwieweit sich das deckt mit meinem PC
Computer
Okay deckt sich schon mal nicht es ist eine Ryzen CPU
Ich wollte mir ja auch
Eigentlich eine Ryzen Kiste bauen
Und ich weiß nicht mehr genau warum ich mich für Intel entschieden habe
Wieder
Ich kriege es nicht mehr zusammen
Entweder war es die Verfügbarkeit
Oder die Single Core Performance
Irgendwas war es
Es hatte auf jeden Fall einen Grund
Warum ich Intel genommen habe und nicht AMD
Naja eigentlich wollte ich eine AMD Kiste bauen
Ich glaube ich habe einfach Benchmarks geguckt und zu dem Zeitpunkt war halt ein bisschen schneller
Naja
Okay
Gucken wir mal die gab es damals noch nicht
Diese X3D Dinger
Was hat er denn?
Den hatte ich auch am alten Rechner
Noctua NH-D15
Den hat immer noch mein alter Rechner
Der steht da hier neben dem neuen
Drinnen
4090 habe ich auch
Dann hat er hier hinten ein Netzteil
Was ist denn das für ein Netzteil?
GX?
Ist das ein Be Quiet?
Guck mal hier das ist mein
Fokus
Dann Asus Mainboard
Rockstrix Gaming WiFi
Die Namen sind auch immer mega nice
Ist doch ordentliche Hardware
Neuer Computer also zumindest die Komponenten davon
Ich habe es gekauft
Ich bin übers Pitch ey wie viel habe ich ausgegeben
Wie ich den zusammengestellt habe
Welche Komponenten ich warum genau ausgesucht habe
Und worauf ihr achten müsst
Wenn ihr euch auch einen neuen
Die gleiche SSD habe ich übrigens auch
Rechner zusammenstellen wollt
Das seht ihr in diesem Video
Unter anderem erzählt euch Christian Hirsch aus dem CT Hardware Rechner
Interessante Erfahrungswerte aus vielen Jahren PC bauen
Für mich ist das hier wirklich ein bisschen emotionaler Moment
Denn für mich ist das der erste wirkliche keine Kompromisse PC
Also ist mir ein bisschen peinlich
Aber ich stehe dazu
Seit ich ein Jugendlicher bin
Warum hat er da einen Super Nintendo Controller gerade in der Hand gehabt?
Keine Kompromisse PC
Also ist mir ein bisschen peinlich
Ist auch noch ein Original
Sieht zumindest sehr original aus Super Nintendo
Europäischer Super Nintendo Controller
Ich stehe dazu
Seit ich ein Jugendlicher bin
Liege ich meinem Computer in der Hand
Und stelle mir vor
Was ich mir für einen tollen PC bauen könnte
Wenn ich unendlich viel Geld dafür brauche
Das mache ich tatsächlich nicht mehr
Das habe ich früher gemacht
Als ich noch nicht die Kohle hatte
Mir sowas selbst zu kaufen
Da habe ich immer darüber fantasiert
Und Mediamarkt Prospekte durchgeblättert
Und so was könntest du dir für einen geilen PC kaufen
Du hättest gern sowas
Nie die Chance gehabt
Und jetzt seitdem ich die Chance habe
Kaufe ich mir alle 3 bis 5 Jahre einfach einen neuen PC
Und dann immer zum jeweiligen Zeitpunkt
Was fettes
Und das hält dann auch wieder eine Weile
Ja ein paar Jahre vorgespult
Jetzt ist es soweit
Ich habe zwar nicht unendlich viel Geld
Aber ich mache so einen YouTube Kanal hier
Wo viel mit KI gebastelt wird
Und wo ich einfach einen Computer
Mit maximaler Power brauche
Also mein PC würde
Mehr VIPisiert aussehen
Das versteht auch mein Arbeitgeber
Also CT bzw. Heise
Und deswegen kann ich jetzt einfach
Einkaufen was ich für sinnvoll halte
Aber natürlich will ich auch vernünftig bleiben
Also im besten Fall hätte ich gern
Also mein nächster PC
Eindeutig
Ich kaufe mir als erstes
Das Weep-Fahrrad
Und dann brauche ich auch so einen LCD im Bildschirm
Für die passende
Ladung
Cuteness
Was zum Beispiel im Leerlauf
Nicht so viel Energie zieht
Brauche auch keine 64...
Ehrlich gesagt jetzt mal ernsthaft
Die letzten 3 PCs
Hatten alle so ein Glas
So ein Gehäuse mit Glas
An der Seite
Und
Ich hatte in den letzten 3 PCs
Auch RGB Beleuchtung drin
Jetzt hier in dem auch
Ich gucke nie rein
Ich gucke legit nie rein
Wofür hast du bisher die Leistung
Deiner 4090 gebraucht
Für das Weihnachtsvideo Witcher 3
Next Gen Edition mit Raytracing
Auf Maximum
Richtig
Also wem das hier nicht aufgefallen ist
Wem das hier nicht aufgefallen ist
Das ist Witcher 3 Next Gen Edition
Raytracing auf Maximum
Das ist wichtig gewesen
Dass das Raytracing auf Maximum war
Und ich glaube das was bisher
Mein PC am meisten geschockt hat
War Alan Wake 2
Mit Raytracing
Das war tatsächlich echt anstrengend
Da hatte ich teilweise sogar nur
Nur 50 FPS
Mit Raytracing voll auf Anschlag und allem
Das muss man sich gar nicht vorstellen
Und
Ansonsten
Wüsste ich jetzt auch nicht
Mein Dark braucht die Leistung
Definitiv nicht
CPU Kerne Workstation
Weil ich die Kerne eh nicht auslasten werde
Bleib dran
Sie merken den Internet Surfer
Herzlich willkommen hier
NordVPN das skippen wir mal
Ende
So wo fängt man jetzt am besten an
Wenn man sich so einen Rechner zusammenstellen will
In deinem Fall
Wo man am besten anfängt
Alles Sachen
Die ziemlich stark auch die Grafik hat
Ich glaube die beste Sache
Womit man anfangen kann
Wenn man einen neuen PC braucht
Ist sich zu überlegen
Wofür man den PC benutzen will
Weil man braucht keine 4090
Wenn man nur olle Sachen spielen will
Oder gar nichts spielen will
Oder nur 16 Bit Systeme emuliert spielen will
Oder was auch immer
Oder halt einfach nur
Nennen wir es mal
Office Sachen erledigen möchte
Irgendwelche Arbeitssachen
Terminal auf IDE auf
Remote Desktop auf die Arbeit auf
Vielleicht für den einen oder anderen noch
Irgendwelche Textverarbeitung
Sachen auf Tabellen
Da brauchst du keine fette Grafiker
Dafür
Da kann es allerdings trotzdem durchaus Sinn machen
Ordentlich RAM reinzustecken
In so einen Office PC
Beanspruch
Das ist halt so in dem Fall würde ich sagen
Die PC sind da richtig gut für
Die haben auch genug Wumms
Die eingebaute Grafikkarte ist gar nicht so schlecht
Für das meiste
Argument bei dir zu gucken
Was ist die passende Grafikkarte
Ok also Komponente 1 Grafikkarte
Ja und da habe ich direkt eine ganz klare Antwort
Aber ihm ist natürlich klar
Er will hauptsächlich wahrscheinlich Gaming und AI Zeug machen
Da ist natürlich eine ordentliche Grafikkarte nicht verkehrt
Ich brauche eine mit Nvidia RTX 4090 GPU
Die 4090 muss es nämlich sein
Weil ich für KI Zeug
Wenn ich Windforce lese
Da muss ich immer an die
GTX
90 80
War das
Denken
Die hatte so ein richtig
Da habe ich damals noch
Also da als ich noch ein bisschen mehr Youtube und Gaming Zeug gemacht habe
Da habe ich damals von Nvidia eine gekriegt
Und das war so eine ganz abgedrehte von der Benahmung her
Das Ding hieß irgendwie
Hercules
Windforce
Irgendwas hier
GTX 780
Inno3D
iChill
GTX 780 Hercules
Moment Moment
Das ist nicht der volle Name
Das Ding hieß noch
Das hatte noch einen längeren Namen
iChill Windforce
iChill Hercules
Ultra Windforce
Das hatte so einen Namen
Das hat nicht auf eine Seite gepasst
Mann
Da ist ja mittlerweile
Einfach nur RTX 4090
Windforce V2
Richtig Easy
Die 4090 muss es nämlich sein
Weil ich für KI Zeug
Vor allem viel Video speichere
Ist das mit einer Grafikkarte auch so wie beim RAM
Hä?
Dass man eine bessere mehr kaufen soll
Nicht zwangsläufig
Also wenn du wirklich jetzt nicht
Irgendwelche KI Render Sachen machen
Oder wenn du keine Render Sachen machen willst
Wenn du keine KI Model Geschichte machen willst
Wenn du keine Games machen willst
Dann reicht dir so ohne Probleme
So eine Integrated GPU
Bei einer so einer
Wie heißen diese Dinger von AMD
Da wo ich auch so eine habe
Ich habe hier so ein Mini PC
Mini Forum
Wie heißt die Kiste die ich hier am Start habe
Mini PCs bei Geizhals
Ne das war schon mal... Bin ich blöd?
Ich habe hier geschrieben wie der Mini PC heißt
Denn ich habe
UM
UM 690
Minis Forum
Das Teil habe ich mir gekauft
So und da hast du drinnen
So eine AMD Ryzen Kombi CPU
Mit Grafikkarte und CPU
Die Grafikkarte da drinnen
Ist gar nicht so schlecht
Also ungefähr dass du dir vorstellen kannst
Auf welchem Niveau sich diese Grafikkarte bewegt
Die Videos haut alle
Du kannst
Ich weiß nicht ob ich auf die Schnelle
Einen ordentlichen
CPU Benchmark finde
Du kannst mit den Dingern
Ja 680M ist da drinnen
Einen ordentlichen Benchmark
Iperf
So 3D Mark oder irgendwas
Wo man
Also zumindest
Wenn mich mein
Also wenn hier Grafikkarte
Ey das ist ja blöd
Ein bisschen Gaming Performance hier
Witcher 3 Borderlands 3
Also kommt mal hier
Hier siehst du es eigentlich ganz gut
Wenn du hier Witcher 3
Ich meine jetzt Low Graphics Post Processing
Du kannst Witcher 3 mit
Low Graphics auf dem Ding
Mit 130 FPS spielen
Also so schlecht sind die Grafikkarten nicht
Nein Low Settings ist halt ein bisschen
Fraglich
Ja
Und hier hast du High Settings
Da hast du 40 FPS
Also es ist gar nicht so übel
Und hier siehst du es auch
Hier siehst du es auch ganz gut
Also was ich im Hinterkopf habe
Guck du kannst Witcher 3
Witcher 3 Next Gen Edition
Kannst du spielen so mit
Ne
Kannst du spielen
So mit 40
40 FPS
Auf mittleren Details
Also es ist jetzt nicht super krass
Was da an GPU drin ist
Aber es ist bei weitem nicht so mies
Wie integrierte
GPUs von früher
Das ist schon echt in Ordnung
Also wenn du mit dem PC tatsächlich
Emulation betreiben willst
Ist das eines der besten PCs überhaupt dafür gewesen
Also meiner Meinung nach
Deswegen habe ich mir auch so einen gekauft
Wenn du aktuelle Spiele spielen willst
Geht das in gewisser Weise auch
Aber dann generell wenn ich aktuelle Spiele spielen will
Würde ich mir kein Mini PC kaufen
Aber für alles andere
Ist diese GPU mehr als ausreichend
Auch auf Dauer
Du musst dir keine fette Grafikkarte kaufen
Wenn du einfach nur vorhast
Gelegentlich irgendwelche Casual Games zu spielen
Oder
Noch besser das als rein Office
Home Office Work PC
Zu verwenden
Da musst du dir halt überlegen was du machen willst
Ne
Wenn du viele Anwendungen offen hast
Und gerade auch viele Browser Sachen im Browser machst
Tabs
Macht durchaus Sinn da eher noch ein bisschen mehr RAM reinzustecken
Nö
Wenn dir nicht klar ist über den Anwendungsfall
Der
Das PC ist
Dann würde ich sagen
Gib lieber ein bisschen mehr Geld aus
Für den RAM
Anstatt dir da jetzt eine fette Kiste hinzustellen
Mit einer GPU die du nicht brauchst
Dann nimm lieber so ein Minis
Minis Forum PC
Der ist schön klein knackig
Nimmt keinen Platz weg
Kann sogar mit der Halterung
Die ist glaube ich sogar dabei gewesen
Mit der Halterung hinter dem Monitor installiert werden
Man muss
Das ist halt echt so eines der wichtigsten Sachen
Da muss ich ein bisschen überlegen
Was man denn mit dem PC wirklich machen will
Und in seinem Fall
Er will spielen und AI Zeug berechnen
Da ist natürlich eine fette GPU nicht verkehrt
Und nur die 4090
Hat 24 GB
Ja es gibt auch AMD Karten mit 24 GB
Die sind auch gut
Aber da ich KI Sachen machen will
Und viele davon die CUDA Programmierschnittstelle nutzen
Und es CUDA nur für Nvidia gibt
NMAC Mini kaufen und gut?
Würde ich nicht unbedingt sagen
Je nachdem was du machen willst
Dann auch nicht
Wenn du einen MAC basierten Workflow hast
Oder mit der Sache klarkommst
Dann schon
Aber einfach nur blind dadurch ersetzen
Würde ich das nicht machen
Außerdem ist der noch ein bisschen teurer
Und das ist auch definitiv der teuerste Teil
Meines Rechners
Denn eine RTX 4090 kostet ungefähr 2000 Euro
Ist das wieder teurer geworden?
Wobei was habe ich dafür nochmal bezahlt?
Was habe ich dafür nochmal bezahlt?
Habe ich das irgendwo im Video eingeblendet?
Ne glaub nicht
Ich habe aber einen Geizhals Link
So
Graph
Ich habe das ungefähr vor einem Jahr gekauft
Ey die Grafikkartenpreise sind ja mal wieder
Richtig krass angezogen
Die letzten Monate
Das ist ja fast auf dem Niveau
Wie das wo ich mir gekauft habe
Guck mal ich habe mir den PC gekauft
Anfang Dezember
Letztes Jahr
Also hier so
So da
Wo es richtig schön teuer war
Und
Im Laufe des Jahres
Gings ja runter von
2200 Euro auf 1700
Und jetzt ist wieder richtig angezogen
Mann
Habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen
Das ist nur bei der 4090 so extrem
Weil die nicht mehr nach China exportiert werden dürfen
Warum werden die teurer
Wenn mehr verfügbar ist?
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht
Okay
Interessant
Gibt es von unterschiedlichen Herstellern
Die da alle ihre eigene Kühlung
Und so weiter draufknallen
Das heißt die unterscheiden sich unter anderem in der Lautstärke
Welche 4090 ist denn jetzt die leiseste?
Immer ein Tipp ist es die sogenannte Founders Edition
Das ist die Karte die Nvidia selber verkauft
Founders Edition ja
Aber die sind natürlich immer ausverkauft
Das ist ganz klar aber das ist aus unserer Erfahrung
Immer mit die
Irgendwie höre ich den nur auf der linken Seite oder?
Ihr auch?
Ja
Die Founders Edition die hätte ich gerne gehabt
Aber habe ich natürlich nicht bekommen
Ach so die Chinesen haben vor dem
Bann noch ihr Lager vollgemacht
Warum darf die 4090
Eigentlich nicht mehr in China verkauft werden?
Wo ist der Sinn davon?
Tausende Karten in China
Zu AI Beschleunigern umgebaut
Nachdem die USA
Die RTX 4090 in China
Auf die Bannliste gesetzt hatte
Warum?
Da gibt es nun in vielen Bildern
Von der chinesischen Social Media Plattform
Baidu
Die Tausende RTX 4090 zeigt
Die in Werkstätten umgebaut und dann als AI beschleunigt
Ja und wo ist das Problem?
Ich meine
Dafür sind die Dinger halt gut geeignet
Seit Monaten werden in China RTX 4090 geortet
Die Preise lagen zwischenzeitlich
Beim dreifachen
Hierzulande ist das deutlich sichtbar
Während der Preis fällt steigt
Ok es steigt nur die 4090 deutlich
In China werden RTX 4090
Zweck entfremdet
Das wird doch Nvidia ziemlich egal sein
Solange sich der Kram wie geschnitten Brot verkauft
Ok
An den Grafikchip zu kommen
Aus den Einzelteilen
Sollen die Fabriken komplett
Neue Beschleuniger fertigen
Hä
Die bauen quasi den GPU aus
Und den RAM aus
Und bauen daraus ne neue Karte
Die Chinesen man
Bestückt mit einem neuen Kühler laufen
Die AI beschleunigen dann ihren Test
Die Chinesen man
Der Band kommt von den USA
Jaja
Sowas in der Richtung habe ich mir gedacht
Nvidia wird es wahrscheinlich gar nicht so geil finden
Es ist in gewisser Weise
Sogar irgendwo nachvollziehbar
Ok gucken wir mal weiter
Irgendwo einen detaillierten Vergleichstest
Mit allen zurzeit erhältlichen
RTX 4090 Karten zu finden
Leider ohne Erfolg
Deshalb habe ich mich einfach für eine entschieden
Die gerade gut lieferbar war
Einige dabei
Achja dass viele dieser Karten
Von den Herstellern etwas übertaktet sind
Das ist echt vernachlässigbar
Also lasst euch davon nicht beziehen
Das ist in der Praxis echt nicht relevant
Das ist nicht relevant und
Du kannst die meisten Karten
Indem du das Powerlimit einfach ein bisschen
Hochstellst
Ohne Probleme aufs gleiche
Übertakten
Komponente Nummer 2 Prozessor
So Grafikkarte haben wir
Jetzt die zweite große Sache nämlich die CPU
Da habe ich ehrlich gesagt am längsten
Darauf rumgekaut
Denn ich will ja möglichst viel Leistung
Was ist denn momentan das Powerkabelmeter
Das ist eine gute Frage
Also ich habe mir
Für mein Netzteil so ein
Extra Stromkabel gekauft
Das sieht man nicht in meinem
Zusammenbau Video
Hatte ich noch das alte
Hallo Leute hier ist der
Ich glaube hier hatte ich noch das alte Kabel
Ne ne ne oder
Es ist schon das neue Kabel
Da haben sich die Leute ja auch aufgeregt
Dass das hier so drüber hängt
Ich muss sagen ich habe das tatsächlich
Mittlerweile hier guck hier sieht man es
Ne Moment das ist die Wasserkühlung
Hier
Ne Moment wo ist denn
Wo ist denn die Grafikkarte
Da unten
Ne hier war glaube ich noch das alte
Hier war noch das mitgelieferte Powerkabel dran
Ohne
Ohne das es direkt zum Netzteil gepasst hat
Da musstest du mit so einem Adapter dran stöpseln
Das war nicht schön
Mittlerweile habe ich den Kram auch hinten rum verlegt
Und hier ist jetzt das Kabel dran
Vom Netzteilhersteller
Man konnte sich vom Netzteilhersteller quasi so ein extra
Powerkabel kaufen
Was du direkt ins Netzteil klipsen kannst
Und dann in die Grafikkarte ohne diesen komischen Adapter
What the fuck
Wo haben wir denn hier stehen geblieben
Im Leerlauf möglichst wenig Strom verbraucht
Weil in der Praxis so ein Rechner ja viel
Im Leerlauf so rumhängt
Die meiste Zeit eidet das
Das kann man sagen von Christian
Intel kriegt halt diese Leerlaufleistungsaufnahme
Im Schnitt besser hin
Das hängt natürlich auch vom jeweiligen Board ab
Also man kriegt Intel Boards mit so 10, 12, 13 Watt
Das Gesamtsystem
Das ist enorm
Hat sich das verbessert die letzten Jahre
Früher waren Idle Dinger
Sind die dann teilweise rumgedüst
Irgendwie auf 40 Watt oder so
40, 50 Watt Idle
Heute hast du kaum noch einen großen Unterschied
Zwischen einem richtig krassen Powerding
Also
Ein PC im Idle Betrieb
Versus einen stromsparender Mini PC
Also
Immer noch ein Unterschied
Die Mini PCs im Idle brauchen teilweise
Irgendwie 5, 6 Watt
Und so ein fetter
So ein fetter PC braucht dann
Vielleicht mit Grafikkarte 20 oder so
Oder 15
Aber es ist halt
Bei weitem nicht mehr so
Dass du fette Gaming PCs hast
Die 40, 50 Watt Idle verbrauchen
Wie es früher war
Und ihr habt dann an der Steckdose
Irgendwelche 13 Watt
Natürlich ohne Grafikkarte
Weil die Grafikkarte kommt immer noch oben drauf
Da kann man auch nochmal so 6 bis 10 Watt rechnen
Also die 13 Watt nur mit interner Grafik
Bei AMD ist man bei der AM5 Plattform
Eher so um die 30 Watt
Schon ein bisschen mehr
Und das liegt halt daran
Dass Intel die Stromsparfunktion
Hört ihr den auch nur auf der linken Seite
Chipsätze besser hinkriegt
Muss man ganz einfach so sagen
AMD Systeme können
Wenn man alles optimiert
Auf knapp 15 Watt kommen
AMD Systeme brauchen mindestens das doppelte
Im Leerlauf
Das ist krass
Okay also ist Intel jetzt einfach effizienter
Ne ne ne ne
Nur im Leerlauf
Wenn man nämlich Leistung abruft
Dann ist AMD effizienter
Schaut mal hier
Das sind Benchmarks von unseren Kollegen von PC Games Hardware
Die haben hier bei mehreren Spielen
Und dann geguckt
Wie viele FPS pro Watt die CPU schafft
Und klar je mehr FPS pro Watt
Desto besser
Und die Ryzens von AMD belegen die komplette Top 10
Erst an 12ter Stelle
Kommt mit dem
15400F
Eine Intel CPU
Und der Unterschied ist erheblich
Unter Volllast
Fallert die schnellste Intel Spiele CPU
Core i9 13900KS
485 Watt weg
Die schnellste AMD Spiele CPU
Ryzen 9
Den hab ich auch oder
Den hab ich auch
Ich bin mir jetzt unschlüssig
Was hab ich für ne
Ne Moment das ist etwas zu alt
13900K
485 Watt weg
Ja die hauen schon ordentlich rein
Ryzen 9 7950X3D
Lediglich 205 Watt
Ja und jetzt kommt's
Laut unserer Spiele und Anwendungs Benchmarks
Ist die AMD CPU
Sogar schneller
Als die Intel CPU
Obwohl sie 2,5 mal weniger Strom aus der Dose zieht
Das war für mich dann das Argument
Auf die
Wenn ich mir jetzt einen Rechner gekauft hätte
Dann hätte ich mir jetzt wahrscheinlich tatsächlich eine AMD gekauft
Obwohl sie 2,5 mal weniger Strom aus der Dose zieht
Das war für mich dann das Argument
Auf die AMD Seite gehen
Auch wenn der 7950X3D
Die seltsame Besonderheit hat
Die 16 Kerne auf 2 Chiplets verteilt
Das ist ja für mich als Anwender wurscht
Einer der Chiplets hat den 96 MB X3D Cache
Der andere nur 32 MB
Deshalb muss das System dafür sorgen
Die Last möglichst sinnvoll auf die Chiplets zu verteilen
Offenbar klappt das nicht immer ganz optimal
Aber das ist mir auch ein bisschen egal
Weil auch ohne perfekte Verteilung
Das Teil immer noch super schnell ist
Also meine Entscheidung
AMD Ryzen 7950X3D
Mit 16 Kernen
Für 530 Euro
Mit viel besserem Preis Leistungsverhältnis
Hat übrigens der 7800X3D
Mit 8 Kernen für 370 Euro
Ja viel günstiger
Aber ich hätte trotzdem auch den fetten gekauft
Hätte ich genauso gemacht wie er
Und bei den meisten Anwendungen und Spielen
Auch nicht unbedingt viel langsamer
Ich wollte aber die 16 Kerne haben
Weil keine Kompromisse
Der 7800X3D ist übrigens auch die CPU Empfehlung
Des optimalen CT PCs 2024
Das Video dazu haben wir euch in der Beschreibung verlinkt
Komponente 3 Mainboard
Ja klar da muss man natürlich erstmal gucken
Welcher Sockel die CPU hat
Bei meiner AMD CPU ist
Ich muss ehrlich sagen
Ich finde die Mainboard Auswahl beim neuen PC
Immer das komplizierteste
Dabei muss man gar nicht auf so viele Sachen gucken
Aber in der heutigen Zeit finde ich es
Sogar noch ein Ticken komplizierter als früher
Weil
Du kannst sowohl bei Intel
Als auch bei AMD
Ältere Chipsätze
Für neuere CPUs verwenden
Und bei AMD sogar ältere Sockel
Das ist teilweise echt
Bisschen tricky
Da durch zu blicken
Ist das zum Beispiel Sockel AM5
Bei aktuellen Intel CPUs
Ist das LGA 1000
Ja und Mainboard sind enorm teuer
Vergleich zu früher
Da gibt es dann allerdings auch wieder unterschiedliche Chipsätze
Es gibt immer einen Einfachspruch
Mit den B Chipsets macht man eigentlich nicht viel falsches
Sowohl bei Intel als auch bei AMD
Genau die A sind die billigen
Die B sind die Standard Golf Klasse
Und X sind glaube ich die genaue
Ach ne, Moment, das ist bei Intel.
Das ist bei Intel, dass die Dinger Z irgendetwas heißen,
die Chipsätze, gell? Bei AMD heißen sie X.
Bei Intel ist es halt H.
Es ist so, wir, es gab
zwischenzeitlich mal X690
und Z690 und sowas,
Chipsätze, man. Die Benahmung war teilweise
so weird, Champ. A, B
und Z, ne? Also H ist billig,
B ist so Standard und Z
sind halt die, für die
Übertaktung und Co. Und ich hab mich entschieden
für B650E.
Kostet immer noch 500 Euro,
das Mainboard. Und hab mich dann aber irgendwie
gewundert, was hat denn jetzt der X
Chipsatz mehr? Also, der
X Chipsatz sind eigentlich zwei B-Chips
hintereinander gekoppelt. Das sind zwei Chips
davon. Man hat dann halt eben
im Prinzip überspitzt gesagt doppelt
so viel USB und PCI-Lanes,
wobei natürlich nicht alle Anschlüsse nach außen
geführt werden, weil ja irgendwann ist der Platz vom Board auch
begrenzt. Der verbraucht dann aber auch mehr.
Der braucht dann deutlich mehr. Also das
sind dann auch, glaube ich, nochmal 10 Watt oder so mehr.
15 Watt knapp. Deshalb würde ich immer sagen,
bei AM5, außer man hat halt
wie gesagt irgendeinen Anwendungsfall,
wo man das dann braucht, würde ich immer sagen
B650 nehmen. Oder die E-Variante
ist dann die, wo dann, glaube ich,
PCIe 5.0 auch am M2-Slot
vorgestellt wird. Genau, das war auch, das war für mich
der Punkt, weil ich auf jeden Fall
auch mal so eine PCI-Express 5.0
SSD testen will.
Mein erster PC, Leute,
mein erster PC,
oder ich weiß nicht, was der
allerallererste PC gekostet
hat, aber der erste
PC, wo ich so richtig so auf Gaming
geschielt habe und sowas, der hat
1000, ziemlich glatt, 1000 Mark
gekostet. Und das war ein
AMD-Fertig-PC mit
einem Pentium 2 400.
Noch
eine ATI-Grafikkarte damals
drinne, die ich dann ausgetauscht
habe zu einer
TNT1
GPU. Und das hat mich
dann in Kombination so
1300 Euro gekostet. Also damals
hast du für, äh, Mark, Mark.
Damals hast du für 300 Mark eine
High-End-Grafikkarte bekommen.
Keck, wait.
Nvidia Riva, Riva hieß das noch.
Nvidia Riva TNT 1.
Das war damals
eine ELSA
E-Razor 2.
Ja.
Nicht PCI.
AGP, mein.
AGP.
Ja. Das Teil,
das war meine erste wirklich
dedizierte Gaming-GPU,
die ich mir zusätzlich zum PC
gekauft habe.
AGP-Slot, also quasi
das, was heute PCI-Express ist.
Damals noch AGP.
Und das war passiv
gekühlt, das Ding, witzigerweise, ne?
Das war super schnell, aber passiv gekühlt.
Da sieht man mal, wie weit, wie
weit das Ganze gekommen ist, mittlerweile.
Wobei die auch
verdammt heiß geworden ist. Die ist richtig
heiß geworden. Also, ich glaube,
ich hab damals sogar, ähm,
tatsächlich dann geschaut, dass ich da irgendwie
einen Gehäuse-Lüfter so hab, dass das, dass das
ordentlich drüber zieht und sowas. Also, die ist
wirklich verdammt heiß geworden, damals schon.
So sah damals eine
High-End-Grafikkarte aus. Das war mit
die schnellste Grafikkarte, die es damals gegeben hat.
Ich vermute mal, das hier ist der Grafik-Speicher
nach wie vor gewesen.
Steht da auch irgendwas drauf, oder?
Ist das, Leute, ist das RAM?
Ich erkenne es anhand der Beschreibung nicht, aber ich vermute
mal, dass das Speicher ist, ne?
Als wurden Soundkarten auch noch heiß.
Ja, damals waren Soundkarten auch noch nicht auf dem
Mainboard drauf. Und das war mein,
mein erster, quasi wirklich
dediziert für Gaming ausgelegter
PC.
Das dürfte so 1997,
98 rum gewesen sein.
Guck mal mal.
Nvidia TNT 1
Release Date
war, ne,
TNT 1.
Nvidia Riva
TNT
Release Date war
am 1998.
Ja.
Ich kann das immer ganz gut damit
äh, äh, äh, ja, äh,
zeitlich eingrenzen, weil ich weiß,
ich hab da mit Half Life gespielt, und Half Life kam
1997 raus.
1998, so in dem Dreh.
Und, damit hab ich
das, hab ich das gespielt.
Also sprich, ja,
das war meine erste Grafikkarte. Und das, wie gesagt, ich hab
für den PC 1000 Mark und für die Grafikkarte 1000
noch mal, also noch mal 300 Mark bezahlt, 1300 Mark
für ein High-End
Gaming PC. Ich glaub, das Ding hat es jetzt schon, oder?
16 MB RAM oder sowas.
Steht da irgendwie, wie viel
steht, wie viel RAM der
dabei hat?
Stand das bei dem,
stand das bei der anderen dabei?
16, 16 MB RAM, ja.
Ja, so sah das damals aus.
Also
Grafikkarten sind schon weit gekommen, was das
angeht.
Bei der Boardsuche auch immer irritiert hat,
dass da immer externe und interne
USB-Anschlüsse angegeben sind.
Was soll das sein? Wo ist der Unterschied?
Ja, extern bedeutet, dass die
Anschlüsse direkt auf dem Mainboard
herausgeführt werden. Man kann also
an diese Buchsen direkt USB-Geräte
anschließen. Intern bedeutet, dass man
die Buchsen noch mit entsprechenden Kabeln
herausführen muss. Das heißt, dass das Gehäuse
das unterstützen muss. Im schlimmsten Fall,
also mit dem falschen Gehäuse, kann man
dann einige der internen Anschlüsse
nicht verwenden. Ich habe mich am Ende
auf jeden Fall für das Board Asus
ROG Strix B650EF
Gaming WiFi
für 280 Euro entschieden.
Komponente 4, Gehäuse.
Ah, das sieht mir
aus wie ein Fractal Design Gehäuse.
Sehr gute
Sache. Fractal Design
R6 oder sowas, R5,
irgendwas in der Richtung.
Gehäuse ist natürlich größtenteils Geschmackssache.
Also klar ist die Funktionalität
wichtig. Also das Ding steht halt im Blickfeld.
Sollte euch also bestenfalls gefallen.
Ich habe die letzten Jahre
quasi, ich dachte, das ist immer
Leute, ich habe es direkt
erkannt.
Ich habe die letzten Jahre
über tatsächlich nur Fractal Design
Gehäuse gehabt. Und dieses
Jahr wäre ich fast abgewichen
von
meinem
Gehäuse-Fanboy-Tum.
Bin dann aber letztendlich trotzdem
gelandet. Aber diesmal
beim Fractal Design
Meshify 2.
Das ist ein Riesending, Alter.
Ich meine, das ist nicht so hoch wie
die Big Tower in den 90er Jahren.
Die waren aber deutlich schlanker.
Die waren einfach nur hoch.
Aber das war
für mich wichtig, weil
man sieht
das ja glaube ich hier im
man sieht es ja glaube ich hier im Video
warum das für mich wichtig ist. Und zwar
erstens mal für die Lüfter und
für die Wasserkühlung hier oben drinnen.
Für die
All-in-One.
Weiß nicht, ob ich da irgendwo mal hochscrolle.
Hier oben ist die Wasserkühlung drin.
Ja, hier sieht man es.
Guck da.
Und nachdem das die Fette
Wasserkühlung ist mit
hundertzwanzig Millimeter
Lüfter.
Ne, hundertvierzig Millimeter
Lüfter. Nicht hundertzwanzig Millimeter.
Hundertvierzig Millimeter Lüfter.
Brauchst du dann ordentlich fettes Gehäuse
für Mikrorisse.
Jaja, ist klar Chat.
Doch, die hätte man
schöner verlegen können. Und die habe ich auch
schöner verlegt.
Ich habe sowohl die
das Mainboard Stromkabel
habe ich hintenrum gemacht und
das GPU Stromkabel
ist jetzt auch eins, was extra zum
Netzteil passt und nicht mehr
das mit Adapter. Das war
aber noch nicht da zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich das Video
aufgenommen habe.
Habe ich mich für das Fractal Design
7 Grey Solid. Sehr gutes Gehäuse.
Sehr gutes Gehäuse.
Aber mit Größe habe ich weniger Probleme
als mit Geräuschen. Und in ein großes
Gehäuse passen viele Lüfter. Ja, und
viele Lüfter sind leiser, auch wenn das erstmal nicht los ist.
Weil es sich langsamer drehen kann. Alle Energie, die wir vorhin
über das Netzteil gesprochen haben, die reingeht, muss ja auch irgendwie
wieder raus. Und das tut sie in Form von Wärme.
Und wenn du da jetzt sagen wir mal spitzenmäßig
irgendwelche, sagen wir mal 600 Watt
oder so rausbringst. Also die Energie, die man
reinsteckt, geht hoffentlich nicht zum größten
Teil über Wärme wieder raus.
Im besten Fall höre ich die aber ja gar nicht, weil
die so leise drehen können. Das ist ja der
Trick. Also lieber mehr Lüfter
als weniger. Das klingt erstmal auf den ersten Blick
nicht einleuchtend, aber dadurch ist ja die Fläche,
wo die Luft rausgefördert wird, größer
und dadurch können die Lüfter dann langsamer drehen.
Also mehr schadet an der Stelle nichts. Ja.
Drei Lüfter werden bei dem Gehäuse mitgeliefert.
Drei habe ich noch dazu gekauft. Und zwar recht
teure, aber dafür leise. Be Quiet
Silent Wings Pro 4 PWM
für 30 Euro das Stück.
Komponente Nummer 5. CPU-Kühler.
Wo wir schon beim Kühlen sind. Auch beim
CPU-Kühler habe ich nicht gespart, weil ich will
es ja leise haben. Ja, der ist gut. Den hatte ich ja
in meinem letzten Rechner auch drin. Deshalb ist
es der Noctua NH-D15
Chromax Black
geworden für 120 Euro. Ja, der taucht. Der hat den
CT-Test immer gut abgeschnitten.
Diesmal als
Rechner mit All-in-One-Wasserkühlung
gebaut.
Und ich muss sagen, bis jetzt
kann ich nicht meckern.
Funktioniert einfach. Komponente 6.
Netzteil. Netzteil soll leise
und effizient sein. Also wenig
Energie nur in Wärme umwandeln.
Dafür gibt es so Effizienzklassen
Gold, Platin, Titan.
Meins hat jetzt 80 plus Gold.
Das ist Standard. Es gibt dann aber noch
Platinum und Titanium oben drüber. Aber
Gold ist das, was man eigentlich schon bei den meisten
Netzteilen kriegt. Was auch völlig okay ist. Da geht's
dann halt irgendwie in der Effizienz um 2-3%.
Ja, das hat 90.
Und das kostet halt einfach dann Unsumme.
Vor allem, also ein Vorteil, wenn
ich das wirklich jetzt aus dem Kopf
genieß das mal immer mit einer Portion Skepsis.
Ich guck jetzt nicht nach. Was ich
im Kopf habe ist, ein Vorteil
der Titanium Specs
ist, dass die
unter anderem strenger sind,
was das Netzteil
an Wirkungsgrad
mindestens haben muss, bei niedriger
Auslastung. Weil die
meisten Netzteile sind bei niedriger Auslastung
nicht sonderlich effektiv.
Und wenn man jetzt ein 600 Watt Netzteil hat,
der Rechner im Idle
aber nur 20 Watt oder 12,
13, 14 Watt verbraucht, ist
natürlich nur ein Bruchteil
dessen, was das Netzteil kann.
Und dementsprechend ist der Wirkungsgrad meistens
in diesen unteren Regionen echt mies.
Im Vergleich zu
ordentlich Auslastung
beim Netzteil.
Und das heißt, du verschenkst da noch ein bisschen
was. Und die
Titanium Specs sind glaube ich ein bisschen
restriktiver, was
das quasi haben darf.
Es macht aber letztendlich nicht wirklich viel
aus, weil
selbst wenn der Wirkungsgrad
super mies ist,
dann verbrauchst du halt
18 Watt
anstatt 12. So what?
Das gilt ja auch nur für
20, 50 und 80
oder 100% Last
im Leerlauf.
Da gibt es glaube ich so gut wie keine Vorgaben
nach dem Standard.
Da bilde ich mir ein, ist das
im Titanium anders. Aber ich glaube
ihm das jetzt einfach mal. Ich meine, er ist der
CT-Hardware-Experte. Ich bilde mir ein,
eines der Vorteile von Titanium
war, dass die auch
im unteren
Auslastungsbereich ein bisschen restriktiver
sind.
Die sind effizient eben deutlich schlechter als diese
80, 90%. Das kann dann
teilweise bei schlechteren Netzteilen bis
50, 60% sein. Gucken wir doch mal.
Äh
Titanium
oder war es Platinium? Ne, Titanium
ist das neue. Titanium
Speck. 80
plus. Ok, hier.
Guck hier.
Genau.
Bei Titanium ist auch das, was ich
sage. Bei Titanium
gibt es sogar
Vorgaben runter bis zu 10%
Auslastung. Das ist genau das, was
ich meine. Ja.
Genau. Titanium
hat, hatte ich doch recht,
Titanium hat noch ein bisschen mehr
Vorgaben, was quasi
im unteren Leistungssegment,
was dann am mindesten Wirkungsgrad
erreicht werden muss. Da brauchst du halt auch mindestens 90%.
Letztendlich macht es jetzt nicht
wirklich viel aus. Aber wenn das Ding idelt,
da hast du halt ein bisschen schlechteren Wirkungsgrad.
Ok, aber es wird, es werden
aus, Rechner braucht 15 Watt,
nicht 50,
was du reinstecken musst.
Brennt dir ja sonst ein Netzteil
durch. Aber ein bisschen
besser ist es. Ansonsten
macht es nicht wirklich viel Unterschied.
Entschieden habe ich mich für das Seasonic Focus
GX 1000 Watt ATX 3.0
für 160 Euro. Der Name
Seasonic
habe ich glaub, Moment,
habe ich ein Be Quiet und Seasonic?
Bin mir jetzt gar nicht so
ganz sicher. Kam beides
nämlich in Frage.
Wo ist mein Netzteil? Be Quiet. Ok, ein Be Quiet
habe ich. Seasonic
kam auch in Frage. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, warum ich
mich für kein Seasonic entschieden habe.
Ich glaube, die waren einfach nicht gut
lieferbar zu dem Zeitpunkt. Das wird es gewesen
sein. Weil ich glaube, ich hatte
die, war mein letzter Rechner
oder die,
die Rackkiste,
irgendwas hatte ich Seasonic und das fand ich auch
ganz nice. Der Name kommt daher, dass
das schon den neuen ATX 3.0
Standard unterstützt. Also es gibt eine neue
Netzteil-Spezifikation, ATX
3.0 nach vielen, vielen Jahren.
Das sind die mit den Grafikkarten-Steckern.
Weil diese modernen Grafikkarten, vor allem bei Nvidia,
diesen neuen 16-poligen Stecker haben.
Der hieß 12-Volt
High Power. Inzwischen
wurde er ein bisschen umgenannt, weil da gab es ein paar Probleme
am Anfang. Das ist auch eine neue Revision.
Da gab es ein paar Probleme, das kann man gut sagen.
Ein paar Sachen haben angefangen
zu fackeln. Wichtig, aber der Unterschied ist halt
zu bisherigen Steckern, zu diesen 8- oder
6-poligen Peck-Stromsteckern, die sind halt dumm.
Da ist einfach, du steckst halt rein und da gibt es halt ein Plus-
und ein Minuspol davon. Und bei diesen neuen
Stecker ist es halt so, die haben halt noch
zusätzliche Kontakte. Also die haben 12 Kontakte
für den Strom, also 6 für Plus,
6 für Masse. Und nochmal 4 Kontakte,
wo die Grafikkarte mit dem Netzteil
kommuniziert. Und wo das Netzteil
meldet, ja, ich kann zum Beispiel 600 Watt
liefern, was der Stecker maximal kann.
Komponente 6 RAM. Also,
dass ich 32 GB RAM haben will,
war klar. Und eigentlich wollte ich auch
sehr schnelles RAM. 64 Gig.
64 Gig. Aber den Zahn...
Ich war ja auch so blöd
und hab 64 Gig eingebaut.
Von denen ich keins brauche.
Aber jetzt...
Ey!
Weil es geht, Mann!
Also wir sagen, es gibt ja Spezifikationen
von AMD und Intel. Bei Intel ist es 5600.
Wenn ich das richtig im Kopf
habe, profitiert tatsächlich
AMD einen Ticken mehr von schnellem
RAM als Intel.
Was habe ich denn für ein RAM nochmal?
Ich habe...
G.Skill Trident Z5
RGB. Schwarz.
Dim. Kit. 64 Gig.
DDR5 6400.
Jawoll. Gib ihm.
RGB. Ganz wichtig.
Mehr FPS.
Es gibt natürlich diesen Overclocker-RAM.
Also mit XMP oder Expo-Profilen.
Die dann auch deutlich schneller laufen und mit
kürzeren Latenzen. Problem ist,
es gibt ja nichts umsonst in der IT. Also
Preis plus...
Die laufen nur mit höherer Spannung.
Und es gab im Frühjahr...
Und im Frühjahr gab es das
große Problem, dass die
Warthersteller ja nicht nur die Speicherspannung hochdrehen,
was ja okay wäre, sondern sie drehen zum Beispiel
auch noch andere IO-Spannungen im Prozessor
hoch. Und das haben sie ein bisschen zu weit getrieben.
Sodass dann vor allem diese X3D-Prozessoren
abgeraucht sind. Oh shit. Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Da gab es wirklich mehrere Fälle. Oh shit.
Im Internet, wo Leute nach wenigen
Wochen plötzlich der Prozessor sich so gewölbt
hatte, kaputt war. Deshalb...
Wenn die CPU sich wölbt, ist glaube ich
echt was im Arsch, ja.
Sind wir sehr große Freunde zu sagen,
jeder kauft, wenn du keine Ahnung
hast, kauf diesen SPD-konformen RAM,
also diesen Standard-RAM. Wenn du basteln
willst oder rumexperimentieren, dann
lies dich vorher ein, gucke genau, was passiert
und halt mit Restrisen gucken.
Die CPU sich wölbt, ist echt kacke. Die Leistungsvorteile,
die ich bei euch gelesen habe, sind ja gering, ja.
Ja, also es hängt ein bisschen davon ab, was
man macht. Also es gibt so Paradebeispiele
wie zum Beispiel 7zip, also Dateien
komprimieren. Bringt extrem viel, aber die Frage ist
natürlich, wie viele Stunden am Tag
komprimiert man Dateien? Prämierst du Dateien, ja.
Die sind ja meistens irgendwie ein paar Minuten, vielleicht Sekunden
oft nur. Dafür lohnt sich das nicht. In Spielen
kann es was bringen, aber auch da ist es ja so,
wenn ich in sehr hohen Auflösungen spiele, also
WQHD oder 4K, dann ist eh die Grafikkarte
der limitierende Faktor, dann bringt der RAM
dann auch nicht mehr viel. Ja, okay, ich bin überzeugt.
Ich hab dann ganz normale RAM-Riegel
innerhalb der Spezifikationen gekauft,
sogar ganz ohne diese coolen
Kühlrippen und RGB. Was?
Alter.
Aber jetzt hat er schon ordentlich Leistung
verschenkt ohne RGB.
Licht und so.
Geworden ist es Crucial Dim Kit
32 GB DDR5
5200.
Für 120 Euro. Cringe,
cringe, wenn man kein RGB
kauft. Weil man immer zwei
Riegel einbauen sollte, weil nur so Dual
Channel funktioniert und das ist schneller.
Komponente 7, SSD.
Das sieht man unter dem Lüfter nicht, ist doch egal,
ob man das sieht. RAM braucht
RGB. Könnte man jetzt schon wieder ein ganzes Video
machen, das machen wir auch bald. Bisschen
Geduld noch. Kurze Zusammenfassung,
eine super schnelle SSD mit PCI Express
5.0 ist mir im Moment noch
mit zu vielen Problemen verbunden.
Vor allem, weil die Dinger halt richtig heiß werden.
Also, mal davon abgesehen, das macht's
auch nicht fett. Was habe ich drinnen?
Eine Samsung SSD 99 Pro
2 TB. Dazu kommt,
ich habe ja nicht nur 2 TB drinnen, ich habe
ja noch ein paar mehr,
noch ein paar mehr Laufwerke drinnen,
wie man sieht. Das ist
die, oh, da muss ich mal ein bisschen aufräumen langsam.
Das ist die 999 Sprit, das ist
noch eine 13 TB
Festplatte, von denen ich kaum
was gebraucht habe bisher, wie man sieht.
Haben dann noch
eine 960 Qvo, die ich hatte,
2 TB, eine BX500 2 TB,
die ich hatte, und auch eine 970 Evo,
die ich hatte. Speicher muss
sein.
Deswegen haben die meisten Mainboards,
richtig, gute Wahl, genau die
habe ich auch. Die meisten Mainboards haben
ja mittlerweile so einen extra
High Performance SSD
Kühl
M2
Slot. Also das ist quasi ein M2
Slot, wo drum herum nochmal
was ist, wo du so ein
Passivkühler
Metall drauf machen kannst.
Also ist ja bei dem, sieht man
ja hier auch, ist bei dem Mainboard
auch so.
Guck hier,
haben die
so eine, also hier ist ein M2 Slot drunter,
und
du kannst quasi hier drunter, kriegst du
so einen Slot
mit einem extra Passivkühler für die
SSD. Hier drunter
könntest du auch noch SSDs machen.
Der Unterschied ist,
zwischen dieser SSD und
diesen zwei, oder drei sogar,
ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele jetzt drunter sind,
SSDs ist,
die hier ist direkt am
PCI Express von der CPU
angebunden, und die hier
ist am PCI Express vom Chipsatz
angebunden. Wenn ich das richtig im Kopf
zusammenkriege.
Da haben sich die Marketingleute
wieder aus den Fingern gesorgt.
Die haben nur PCI Express 4.0,
sind aber trotzdem ziemlich schnell.
Saumäßig schnell, ja.
Mehr als ausreichend schnell.
Warum ich so viel SSD-Platz brauche?
A, weil KI-Modelle riesig sind,
und B, weil ich
viel mit Betriebssystemen mache,
und gern noch Platz für 4-5
Betriebssystem-Installationen
parallel hätte.
Okay, das ist jetzt eine ziemlich
spezielles Nutzungsszenario,
aber ist ja mein PC.
Und ich kann es auch echt fast gar nicht
mehr erwarten, den endlich zusammenzubauen,
aber morgen, also wenn ihr dieses Video
direkt nach der Veröffentlichung guckt,
morgen, Freitag, 22. Dezember,
ab 13 Uhr,
baue ich den Rechner live hier
auf YouTube zusammen. Der Link auf den
Livestream ist schon hier.
Wetten, dass dort auch wieder irgendwelche
Leute im Chat waren, so nach dem Motto,
du machst das falsch, Mikro-Risse im
Mainboard. Ich muss sagen,
sonderlich ordentlich habe ich es im Stream auch nicht
zusammengebaut. Mein größtes Problem im Stream,
als ich den Rechner zusammengebaut habe, war,
dass ich dank der Kamera und dem Winkel,
wie ich den hier liegen hatte, manchmal gar
nichts gesehen habe richtig.
Aber scheint ja mit
Mikro-Rissen nicht so schlimm
gewesen zu sein.
Aber das Backseating war schon hart.
Gucken wir mal.
Zusammenbauen.
Ja.
Das hält auch gar nicht.
Ach, die Musik im Hinterkopf.
Ähm.
Ach, das war das, wo ich mit dieser
Thermal-Grizzly-Platte gekämpft
habe, wo ich nicht genau wusste, wie das funzt.
Ja.
Warum genau habe ich da noch
mal so eine Thermal-Grizzly-Platte?
Ah, für die Wasserkühlung. Ja,
logisch, logisch. Deswegen.
Ist Thermal-Grizzly
nicht
vom Bauer die
Marke? Oder wahrscheinlich
nicht vom Bauer oder doch?
Von Caseking
Zusammenarbeit mit der
Auer.
Ja.
Da habe ich mir ein bisschen
ein bisschen abgebrochen,
bis das funktioniert hat mit dieser
Thermal-Grizzly-Platte.
Ja, und dann habe ich es mal
ausprobiert mit der
Wasserkühlung.
Ja, das Mainboard steht ein bisschen wackelig.
Ist durchaus okay.
War quasi erster Start hier.
RGB-RAM, ganz wichtig.
Schon das
Bauer-Drama-Video gesehen.
Was ist denn
jetzt schon wieder auf
Hardware-YouTube-Deutschland los?
Endlich ein gutes externes
Hardware-Display. Der Gipfel
der Kritikunfähigkeit.
Das gucke ich mir jetzt nicht an.
Hardware-YouTuber-Drama
brauche ich nicht.
Muss ich mir nicht geben.
Das Video war fertig, was wir jetzt
geguckt haben, ne?
Das nehmen wir wieder zu.
Auch zu.
Ach nee.
YouTube-Drama brauche ich nicht.
Ich habe mich auch aus der
Pentanuke-Sache damals rausgehalten.
Wenn sich noch einer erinnern kann.
Oh gut.
Damit hätte ich jetzt hier nichts zu tun.
Würde es einfach nur angucken, aber
es interessiert mich auch überhaupt nicht.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Das gucken wir mal.
Den Blindfolded
Blindfolded
Zero Star Speedrun Mario 64
Wollte ich mir die ganze Zeit
schon angucken.
Ist bei weitem nicht der erste Speedrun
den wir uns angeguckt haben.
Aber der erste
Blindfolded Speedrun
War das nicht die gefakte Pentanuke
damals? Doch.
Also noch ist es nicht Blindfolded.
Aber ich vermute mal jetzt, wenn es losgeht
wird, dass ich Blindfolden.
Dann erst mal 500 APM am N64
Controller.
Wie lange hat er das geübt, ey?
Das mache ich nicht mal, wenn ich hingucke.
Alter, die sind doch verrückt
mittlerweile.
Ich meine.
Also es ist nicht mal so, als könnte ich das,
wenn ich hingucke.
Wie oft hat er das
ausprobiert?
Und er muss das ja relativ konsistent hinkriegen.
Weil das geht ja eine Weile.
Blub.
Oh Mann.
Also was ich mal.
We did it.
Also was ich mal gelesen habe.
Oder ich glaube nicht gelesen.
Ich glaube sogar ein Video von ihm dazu war das.
Zu Blindfolded. Das ist nicht Fake.
Zu Blindfolded Speedruns.
Dass da sehr viel
daran festgemacht wird.
An der Musik vom jeweiligen Level.
Wo du jetzt gerade bist.
Und natürlich auch an,
dass du sehr viele Setups brauchst.
So nach dem Motto. Du gehst an diese Ecke.
Hörst, dass Mario am Geländer schleift.
Dann weißt du, du bist in diesem Winkel.
Und dann musst du bis zum so und sovielten
Musiktick da und da sein.
Und sowas.
Ich meine klar. Du musst dir irgendwas über.
Ich glaube Audio Cues wird das dann quasi genannt.
Du musst ja sehr viel über
Informationen, die dir das Game gibt.
Die du nicht siehst halt machen. Logisch.
Jetzt hört er erst an diesem
komischen Kristall dran.
Jetzt weiß er,
er ist richtig.
Das ist trotzdem übertrieben.
Wie viel Übung da reingeflossen sein muss.
Ich meine, man darf nicht vergessen.
Das Movement von ihm
in diesem Level sieht Blindfolded
flüssiger aus als 90% der Casual
Spieler, die was sehen können.
Jetzt wird durchgelaufen.
Das Game ist schon ziemlich
broken. So long
Gay Bowser.
Wie auch immer das funktioniert hat.
Mario 64 ist ja nicht
gerade dafür bekannt, fehlerfrei zu sein.
So, jetzt wird
rausgequittet.
Gehe ich von aus? Ja, okay. Das passiert nämlich an der Stelle
immer. So, wohlgemerkt,
das ist Zero Star.
Das heißt, damit Zero Star funktioniert,
bedeutet, er muss sich
jetzt, also normalerweise wäre die Route
jetzt, man geht in Keller,
geht in das Sandlevel,
in das Feuerlevel, in die
Oh, wie
heißt diese, diese nochmal mit der Metall
Kappe, das Level, diese Krotte,
sammelt da ein paar Sterne
und dann geht man weiter.
Aber nachdem das Zero Star ist, bedeutet
das, der muss sich jetzt
irgendwie, und da bin ich mal gespannt, wie er das
macht, links ist ja die Tür, wo es zum nächsten
Boss geht, er muss sich da links irgendwie
durchglitschen. Und er hat auch nicht den
Hase, kritischer
Hase, weil der spawnt jetzt noch
nicht. Okay, das ist jetzt irgendeine
Setup-Geschichte, dass er blind weiß,
wo er ist. 300
BPM auf dem A-Button.
Alter, da fällt der Finger ja ab. Okay, hat nicht
geklappt. Vermutlich.
Jetzt,
guck, jetzt wusste er, wo er ist. Er war
sich, also ich vermute, dass es folgendes war.
Er war sich nicht sicher,
ob das durch die Wand klitschen geklappt
hat. Und um zu checken, ob er
durch die Wand geklitscht ist, läuft er nach rechts,
hört, er rutscht die, rutscht
die Rutsche runter und weiß
jetzt, ich bin nicht durch
die Wand gekommen. Meine Vermutung
dazu.
Geh zur rechten Seite. Ja.
Ah, 1. Versuch SPLJs. Wir haben
jeden, jeden
Rennen, wie 1. oder 2. Versuch SPLJs
heute. Es ist absolut verrückt, Mann.
Und wie ist die Tür zur linken Seite?
Jetzt weiß er nicht, wo er ist, hm?
Ja, das
verwirrt mich wirklich, wo ich bin.
Das ist halt das Blöde, wenn du nichts siehst.
Bei uns sieht es jetzt total offiziell aus,
aber er hat keine Ahnung, wo er gerade ist.
Wie? Was?
Oh, ich bin nicht in C-Down.
Offiziell.
Ja.
Was auch immer.
Dachte er ist Pro, wie kann sowas passieren?
Chat hätte es bestimmt besser gemacht.
Okay, nochmal.
Nochmal.
Okay, das hat nicht geklappt.
Okay, aber da sieht man, dass das sein Setup ist,
im Endeffekt, um an die richtige Position
zu kommen. Deswegen ist es immer
die gleiche, also das hast du ja in vielen Speedrun-Games,
wenn es super komplizierte
Tricks gibt, gibt...
Es gibt manche Tricks, die kriegen die Leute
mittlerweile quasi so First
Try, so flüssig aus dem
Gameplay hin,
aber für manche Sachen brauchst du halt irgendein Setup.
Deswegen Pause, also ihr kennt
das vielleicht aus Ocarina of Time, da wird
da total auf Pause gedrückt. Das ist halt auch
genau deswegen, dass du den richtigen Frame
abpasst, in dem du was machen musst.
Und hier, dass du halt dich in die richtige Position
bewegst. Die gucken halt, okay, von
dieser Ausgangsposition,
mit reproduzierbaren Movements,
wie komme ich immer wieder in
exakt Pixel genau die richtige Position,
in die ich hin muss. Und das
ist halt der Trick an der Stelle, anscheinend
dazu. In die
Tür-durch-Glitch-Position zu kommen.
Ja.
Hat wieder nicht funktioniert.
Oh!
Habt ihr eigentlich mitbekommen, dass Mario jetzt einen neuen
Sprecher hat? Irgendein
Typ, der auch Genshin Impact-Charakter
voicet, ist nicht mal der
gleiche. Ist nicht mal Charles
Martinet, hieß er glaube ich.
Sondern ist jetzt irgendein anderer Typ.
Okay, jetzt, ha?
Immer noch nicht.
Aber wie kommen die Leute drauf?
Da muss man ja stundenlang jedes Frame
testen und schauen, ob ein Bug entsteht. Ja.
Wobei, mittlerweile sind ja viele
grundsätzliche Movement-Glitches in
Mario 64 bekannt. Also,
sag ich jetzt als jemand, der nicht große,
keine Speedrun-Erfahrung hat in dem Game.
Also, die ganzen
Movement-Mechanics und Glitches sind bekannt.
Ich gehe ganz stark davon aus,
dass das hier eine,
ein Glitch ist,
der auch an anderen Stellen
funktioniert und den man jetzt hier nur
verwendet, der aber an dieser Stelle, weil die
Treppe eben so klein ist, vom Winkel her,
schlecht funktioniert. Das
dürfte im Kern das gleiche sein, wie die
Leute benutzen, um später die Treppen hochzukommen.
Rückwärts.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass hier die Treppe
halt so klein ist.
Und da gibt's ja verschiedene Möglichkeiten, das rauszufinden.
Es gibt Leute, die dekompilieren das Game.
Es gibt Leute, die machen das mit
irgendeiner TAS-Software, wirklich Frame für Frame,
gucken sich das Ganze an.
Und es gibt mittlerweile, das habe ich auch gelesen,
beziehungsweise habe ich auch ein Video zuschauen geguckt,
es gibt mittlerweile
AI-Testing-Programme,
die spielen das Level
milliardenfach durch.
Allerdings nicht Echtzeit, sondern
dadurch, dass Mario 64 ja mittlerweile quasi
auch als Native-PC-Bild vorliegt,
spielen die Mario 64 quasi auf
Ultra-Geschwindigkeit
milliardenfach die Level durch und gucken,
ob sie neue Wege finden mit AI.
Das ist ganz abgedreht.
Aber das Ding ist halt, nur weil was für AI möglich ist,
heißt das noch lange nicht, dass das
human possible von den Inputs her ist.
Es gibt beispielsweise einen neuen Klitsch,
habe ich letztens ein Video drüber gesehen,
auf, ähm, wie heißt die,
diese Rainbow, ähm,
wie heißt die Mario 64 Level?
Das mit den Regenbogen.
Das, wo du da normalerweise
mit dem Teppich fährst auf dem
Regenbogen. Und da gibt's
einen neuen Klitsch, wie man quasi aus
diesem Haus, aus dem Fenster springen kann
und quasi sich aufs Dach
klitschen kann. Was aber super kompliziert
ist von den Inputs her.
Mal gucken, ob's jetzt klappt.
Und, und, und, oh, das sieht gut aus.
Gib ihm.
500 APM. A-Knopf.
Spammen.
Ah, ah, ah, ah!
Nee, hat wieder nicht geklappt.
Und es funktioniert nicht.
Which means we're very close.
Ach, hier, hier hat das,
hier hat das, nee, warte mal.
Ich glaube auch,
hat kein Bock mehr.
Wo schafft das denn?
Hier hat das immer noch nicht geschafft.
Hier resette das irgendwann.
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Hier hat das immer noch nicht geschafft.
Hier ist er durch, hier ist er durch.
Hier. Jetzt gib ihm.
Alter.
Ja.
Oder?
Und jetzt durch,
durch, flupp.
Yay, jawoll.
Ich glaube,
er, er hat's, er hat's geschafft.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt muss er, glaube ich,
grad noch checken, wo er eigentlich ist.
Er ist etwas angespannt.
Okay, nice.
Jawoll.
Bitch.
Jetzt weiß er, jetzt weiß er, dass er's erwischt hat.
Das ist alles geplant.
No, no, no, no.
Nein, nein.
Back up, back up.
Close, close.
Alter.
Back up, back up, back up.
Morgen, KS.
Das war echt knapp.
Krasser Dude, ey.
So, jetzt ist die Kamera ein bisschen geklatscht.
So minimal.
Aber macht ja nix.
Er muss ja nix sehen,
weil er sieht ja auch sonst nix.
Okay, jetzt hat's die Kamera gecheckt.
Jetzt weiß er auch wieder, wo er ist.
Okay, das wusste er vorher auch schon,
aber ich denke mal, die Münze hat das jetzt bestätigt.
Äh, also.
Alles klar.
Also, er weiß ja, wo er ist, aber ich seh nix.
Ah.
Ah, der versucht jetzt, ich glaube,
der versucht jetzt da vorne sich runterhängen zu lassen,
dass er weiß, dass er in der richtigen Ecke ist.
Oder?
Ja, genau.
Das ist, nein, nein, das ist kein Face Reveal.
Okay, jetzt weiß er, dass er richtig ist.
Er, er, er scheint,
er scheint, er scheint,
er scheint, er scheint, minimals angespannt zu sein.
Okay, jetzt hat er den Winkel richtig raus.
Also, ich vermute mal,
es war jetzt so, er ist hier in die Ecke, wusste,
dass er eben hier
an der richtigen Stelle ist, dann ist er rüber,
dass er das Herz gehört hat, wusste, er ist in der Mitte
und dann kann er springen.
Leute, falls das Level
mal jemand gespielt hat, als Casual Noob
in Mario 64, war das gar nicht so einfach.
Genau.
Wow. Nice.
Nice.
Alter, krasser Shit, man.
Das musst du blind erstmal hinkriegen, ey.
Boah.
Äh.
Das Crappen hat nicht geklappt.
Ach doch. Okay, Mario, just Mario 64
things.
Yes, dude!
Ey, raste da aus.
It's over, man!
It's over!
Ne, Moment.
Er muss es, er muss es ja noch durchspielen.
Yes!
Oh, Gott!
Er muss es ja noch durchspielen, ja.
Call Twitter, call Discord, everyone needs to get into
this damn stream, dude.
Aber wahrscheinlich hat er das andere schon so oft
gemacht, dass er das jetzt, dass das jetzt easy
für ihn ist.
Call everyone, man.
Ah, nicht zu früh freuen.
Na gut, ich meine, wir können uns das jetzt angucken,
weil wir wissen, dass es geklappt hat.
Oh, my God, dude.
My heart rate
is like
very dangerous zones,
but it's okay.
I'm calming down slowly.
Ja, es wird Pulsgurt, ey.
Sweet dream!
So. Und jetzt noch mal
die Treppe. Da sieht man,
den Part hat er wohl schon deutlich öfters
gemacht, hä? Alter, der ist, der
ist einfach schneller wie jeder 0815 casual
Dude, der es sieht.
Doch, ich glaube ihm das.
Der ist auch bekannt als
Blindfolded Speedrunner. Da ist nichts
gecheatet. Das ist alles 100%
legit. Das glaube ich.
Okay, jetzt bloß nichts mehr verkacken.
Was gibt das, wenn's
fertig ist? Monkass?
Das sieht ja schon beim Zugucken
gefährlich aus.
Alles klar!
Alles klar! Natürlich!
Was sonst?
Wow! Wow, das war auch richtig
close, wie er da durchgekommen ist, ey.
Da, fuck, Alter.
Das ist richtig,
richtig krass.
Jetzt noch, jetzt noch Nerven behalten.
Woo!
Das ist, okay, das ist definitiv Setup,
alles. Das, das ist,
das ist so geplant, dass das so passiert.
Ja.
Nice!
Boah! Solange,
Bowser.
Nein!
I threw 500 years
too early, man.
The Nerves. But RNG back up.
RNG back up.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
He was up. Monkass?
Monkass?
Nein!
Also, just a prank, bro.
Just a prank. Don't worry about it.
It's all good.
Hey, I gotta, I gotta
make the future generation
a bit of a head start, you know? Like,
I don't want to make this run unbeatable.
M?
Why am I pausing so early, dude?
So, jetzt kommt, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh! Okay, nochmal.
Two one-ups, right? No, we did not die.
Team, okay.
I, I'm so nervous. Warum drückt
er Pause? Ich vermute mal,
dass er besser die Position feststellen kann,
wo er ist.
Oder eventuell, um irgendwas zu, zu,
zu pause buffern in dem
Rahmen, dass er den richtigen Frame für irgendwas erwischt.
Warum er an der Stelle Pause drückt,
weiß ich auch nicht genau.
Don't cry so much, danke für den Sub.
I don't know how I did Skye, honestly.
Oh, shit!
Ah!
Die, jetzt, jetzt gehen die Nerven ein bisschen durch
mit ihm, ha?
I really don't know. Er war so close
beim ersten Mal schon.
Jawoll, jawoll, jawoll, jawoll.
Ja, sauber.
Warum drückt er da Pause? Ich weiß nicht.
Vielleicht, dass die Kamera sich resettet?
Kann das sein, dass das
irgendeine Kamera-Geschichte ist?
Dass er, dass er garantiert in die richtige Richtung rennt?
Wegen der Pause?
Why am I pausing so early, man?
I cannot pause
buffer at all for sounds.
My, my, my, my arms
are just like shaking.
Ja.
Jawoll, jawoll, jawoll.
So, jetzt easy.
Easy. Easy win.
Jawoll, nice.
Jetzt.
Gib ihm, gib ihm.
Gib ihm.
Ah, das sieht gut aus.
Jawoll.
Get out of here.
World's first
zero star
blindfolded dude. Let's go.
Yeah.
Easy.
Easy as fuck.
Heftige Sache.
Easy clap.
I don't know.
Heftig.
Jetzt ist er fertig mit den Nerven.
Krass.
Weil man sieht, es ist da noch,
es ist da noch sehr viel Optimierungspotential
vorhanden. Mich würde es,
mich würde es nicht wundern,
wenn der nicht einfach
weitermacht und irgendwie einen Monat noch
bessere Zeit hat. Aber schon krasser Shit, man.
Muss ich das mal überlegen.
Die Leute hatten früher Probleme,
das Game durchzuspielen. Ich meine, wir waren damals
auch alle Ultra-Kack-Noobs, ja.
Das Spiel durchzuspielen mit, ähm,
mit
selbst was sehen dabei.
Und man muss sagen,
der ist schneller und besser,
als wenn wir das sehen.
Und wir haben es 2023
tatsächlich Zero Star
Blindfolded. Meine Güte.
Was kommt denn als nächstes?
Blindfolded nur rückwärts laufen,
oder?
Scheiß.
Heftig. Also,
mich würde interessieren, wie viele Stunden
er in Mario 64 hat.
Wahrscheinlich
10.000 plus.
Weil gerade für
solche Blindfolded-Sachen
musst du natürlich auch enorm viel auswendig lernen.
Ich meine, du musst so schon wahrscheinlich enorm viel auswendig lernen.
Aber da musst du halt noch mehr
auswendig lernen. Da brauchst du richtig
Big Brain für, um dir das alles merken
zu können.
Okay, Leute.
Ich geh jetzt was essen.
Und wir sehen uns. Bis dann. Macht's gut.
Nudel mit Lachs.
Was sonst?
Wir sehen uns vielleicht nachher. Wenn nicht, spätestens
morgen. Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.